hey guys pete here
there isn't a new episode of better call
saul this week but we can still talk
about it
now that we've had a week to process
things i wanted to come back and have
another discussion
i know my feelings have been evolving
and i'm starting to think more about the
end of everything at this point the end
of the series with only six more
episodes to go
so i brought my friends in and i'm gonna
let my guests introduce themselves
and will
kind of give us an idea
what they're thinking where the what
they're where they're at
after
thinking about this mid-season finale
for a week
i've been working on some new videos and
my thoughts have changed some um i'm
thinking a lot more about how the last
six episodes are gonna connect the two
series how we're gonna start to see
it really become
fused with breaking bad um eric i know
this is your first time here so you can
just basically tell us whatever you like
about your experience watching season
six so far
and you know what you're doing over on
your channel
chase you know why don't you go first uh
what are you thinking about during this
mid-season break and uh
how how things evolved for you since
last week
well uh first off i'm curious as to how
jimmy and kim could cover up howard's
death and
any recent connections to him they never
anticipated on him dying they just
figured he'd eventually land on his feet
so uh with howard possibly going missing
will people such as cliff look into
connections with jimmy i'm just curious
how or if jimmy will cover their tracks
i mean there's obviously everything in
regards to the body but i'm more
thinking about any sort of connections
that could recently uh lead people back
to jimmy and what he was doing because
uh looking at the mediator con um could
the camera crew get involved i mean
after the last episode it kind of seems
like the camera crew got their final
swan swan song and we might not see them
anymore but i mean they are heavily
involved with the final moments of this
uh the camera guy saw jimmy and kim
lacing the photos with drugs and the the
boom mic guy was even in the swapped
photo as the guy handing jimmy a frisbee
so that's something to think about now
since cliff announced that he will be
settling the sandpiper case i'm also
wondering how soon we'll see jimmy and
kim get that money and how it could
impact the final episodes of the show
will jimmy finally get his cadillac with
the money that he has in breaking bad or
could that be a reward of sorts that
wallow gives him on behalf of the cartel
for cooperating because that's kind of
been the leading theory since season
five and then also will kim finally get
her pro bono office with uh other
paralegals such as viola to assist her
we saw kim go down bad choice road with
howard instead of trying to accomplish
her dreams legitimately with that santa
fe meeting and everything that cliff was
offering her so could it still all turn
out for her or will she not be able to
go through with it after howard's death
uh what do you guys think about all that
i i i'll i'll let um
i'll i'll just i'll let eric go ahead
and introduce himself and then i'll i'll
i'll uh
chime in on the uh you know at the end
on what what's going on with that so
eric why don't you once you tell the
viewers who you are and what you do over
on your channel sure thank you well
first of all thank you for having me and
uh for the past couple years now i've
been running inside the gilliverse um
where we talk to the actors and castle
crew each week and
and it's it's been a really really fun
project it started off as a hobby over
on a music side of the the channel uh
where we talked to him you know music
celebrities that we've enjoyed uh
growing up listening to and things like
that and we kind of
brought in some breaking bad and better
call saul characters and then it evolved
into its own thing and
so that's what i do every friday every
friday night and as i was telling you
off the air i love to listen to chase's
theories uh um i i don't get too down i
don't go too far down rabbit holes of
theories because you can get lost
quickly but he has has some great stuff
and something i've learned as of late
um in the past especially having tom on
again the other night sometimes a lot of
people um think all these little dots
that connect things actually don't you
know like if is this a coincidence that
this said this and this said this and a
lot of times just it's just that wasn't
even planned and tom kind of kissed a
lot of um i don't want to say theories
but just coincidences you know um
it was it's neat to hear that from tom
himself so a lot of these things aren't
really what we think so just follow the
narrative um i i see a lot of people
talking about how they think season six
is slow i don't think it's slow at all i
think sometimes people want to see
people killed in every episode and then
we've who we got left
uh i love the pacing of the show um i
was gonna ask tom this the other night
and i didn't but i'll ask you guys as
you can you can both answer have you
ever found yourselves
pausing the episode to see um because i
have amc plus and i so sometimes i'll
pause and i hate doing that to see how
much time is left in the episode and
then it kind of spoils it's like oh man
there's only like nine minutes left
something's gonna like what's gonna
happen in these nine minutes and i try
not to do that but
it that's a it's a real thing i'm trying
to get myself out of doing but i just i
love watching the show i am i don't
profess to be a know-it-all i'm far from
it i my our viewers educate me every
night our guests educate me every night
so i just love
being in this community with all of you
yeah and i just want to the you you keep
mentioning tom i i don't know if you
made it clear that you were talking
about tom schnauz who who is a writer
executive producer director on the show
right correct yeah he he's also my
co-host he uh he co-hosted uh ten
episodes in season one and then he had
to um take a you know a hiatus because
he was writing season six and that's
when coveted all hit and everything and
it was uh you know back in the virtual
writers room but he vowed that when uh
he was free he'd come back and do um the
co-hosting um spot again which will be
probably this uh this season again as
well too
yeah and uh
i was telling you off off screen before
we got started that i've always been
kind of fascinated with his his career
because he's been involved with so much
uh
of you know all this stuff that we watch
and um you know he's really he you know
he would wrote and direct the last
episode that we're we're talking about
right now
and uh it's really cool that you get to
get to sit down next to him and talk
about the about the uh the things that
are going on with you know no knowledge
compared to the fact that he knows where
everything's going
and um yeah uh what you were talking
about there chase going back um
so you're thinking a lot more about the
future of the plot threads that that
were all kind of
going on before lalo showed up you know
you're talking about uh sandpiper money
and the pro bono office and stuff like
that that's that's interesting because
i you know over the last few days most
of my thinking has just been
it feels like lolo has come in
and he sort of
kind of he's he became this like um
you know he's like he's like a planet
you know he has everything he sucked it
into his orbit he has this gravity about
him
and it's kind of hard to see how
that other stuff is going to fall into
place because like you mentioned
howard's dead bodies in their living
room right now like they have to
definitely that that has to be taken
care of and i i think there's a very
very real possibility that lalo once he
kills
howard in front of them
he really has no reason to let them go
you know they're
it's not like he can just say hey go
ahead and uh go to work and then
hit me up at five o'clock and we're
gonna and we'll talk about how we'll
we'll go get gus you know what i mean
yeah like like the both of those
everything is kind of sucked into his
orbit at this point and and that's
really that's really what you know i've
been i've been thinking about and i mean
not that all of what you're saying isn't
good points
it's just uh you know it's it's
interesting that that we're thinking
about you two different two different
you know two different trajectories and
we really don't know how the how which
direction it can go or how it's going to
get there
so it's pretty exciting and um
i i guess we have a couple of super
chats here that i'll hit up first and
then we'll talk about that a little bit
we'll talk about
lalo first and then we'll get into
howard and and you know some of the
things that we
that we need to address um
post
post episode seven
so here we go um
i have this this is a super chat from
almeida's army thank you for the 449
pounds
says could you discuss my theory i
tweeted to you on how
walt and jesse will appear in the
opening of the 608 in a flash forward to
jane's death and i i did see this tweet
on my timeline it was uh
it's basically
the the 608 would open with this flash
forward and
you would see um
jesse there
and he's he basically
makes the call call walt ends up calling
saul and
we know he sends mike over there to
clean things up
so
that that's the theory um
i'll let you guys uh
i'll let you guys go ahead and and chime
in first chase what do you think about
this is as a way to bring walt and jesse
into the story
i mean i mean there's a lot of different
uh flash forward sort of theories that
we could go with i actually haven't
really thought about this one too much
but it does make sense considering that
you know the first time we ever saw mike
in breaking bad it was him cleaning up
jane's death so i think that that could
connect to uh the current events and
better call saul and hypothetically if
somehow jimmy and kim you know get away
from lalo and lalo leaves them with the
body i do think that you know they'll
call mike up and get him to come clean
up the body but
also in such a way that you know maybe
lalo doesn't leave and maybe their
connection with mike is sort of the
thing that lala wants so for all we know
lalo could get jimmy and kim to invite
mike over while he's still there and
have mike clean up the body in front of
them
i'm not sure if he's going to clean up
the body all by himself like he did with
kind of cleaning up the crime scene with
jane's death or if uh he's gonna get his
men over lalo probably doesn't want to
get outnumbered so it might just be mike
i'm just wondering how we'll see a
different perspective of this uh jane
death scene because they don't want to
just show the same thing again they want
to show i mean they might but from a
different perspective maybe seeing more
beforehand or more afterwards but the
whole uh
the whole the whole thing about mike
cleaning up jane is that we see when
mike arrives and we see when he leaves
so i'm not exactly sure um how they
could incorporate more into this scene
all right eric you have anything you
want to add to that
no i think he nailed it and i think
that'd be a very good way to tie the man
having mike arrive uh somehow in a
different perspective different
viewpoint uh
at the apartment or jane's place and
then seeing that clean up at
kim's place i don't know how that's
gonna happen uh what there's gonna be
more people like chase said um but i
think that'd be a perfect way to
introduce them but other than that i
have no clue on how we're going to see
them and i don't think it's just gonna
be fan service i think it's gonna be
something that's gonna be i mean as we
know they they tell stories for a reason
um i don't have a clue at this point and
sometimes i'm happy with that sometimes
i'm disappointed that i don't have these
theories
but uh i just let the story dictate and
uh i'm really anxious to see how they're
going to appear
yeah i i think um
when i read this i
at first i guess my initial reaction was
i didn't understand how it would
it wasn't immediately apparent to me how
that would serve the story that they're
telling right now like i i see the
parallel and and and that does make
sense
but i i have a feeling i mean
it doesn't really change what we what we
know about
uh mike or saul i i kind of feel like
whatever we get as far as a flash
forward and maybe we get that um you
know the roshaman effect where
we see something
from a different perspective and that
person completely uh you know sort of
experiences it or or explains it or
understands it differently than than the
person that we saw during the original
timeline i think um
i don't see that i think this is more of
a of the the the things these two
situations mirror each other a little
bit but i don't really see how they they
expand on on the characters like who
they are or
you know we'll just have to wait and see
i think that you know that that that
would be my my take on on this i i to
say that i don't know how they'll show
up we'll get into that a little bit
later but um
they do have quite a few you know they
have a lot of material to work with
there so it'll be interesting to see
mike johnson
the runner
thank you for the 499. hey pete and the
gang do you think howard hamlin's name
and legacy will get a road to redemption
twist it deserves um
i don't hold out much hope for that
personally
i felt like
that was part of the tragedy was that
there there the way that they crafted
his
this narrative of of him being an addict
for their purposes like i feel like
that's going to kind of tarnish his
his uh
legacy and and that's part of the
tragedy of what their unintended
consequences were like i think that
he um
he deserves better but i don't i don't
know that we we could expect him to get
better and i think that
um one of the things that comes to mind
is that scene where we see that chuck
you know the new intern or the new hire
didn't really know who chuck was just to
see his his image and i thought that was
a pretty big you know
thing like hey look you know chuck's
legacy isn't what it should have been
because of
this thing that happened to him
so what do you what do you think about
this uh chase do you think there's a
a redemption for his
uh reputation or his legacy
i mean unless cliff goes on some sort of
vendetta to prove that howard wasn't
crazy um i'm not too sure and that's
sort of part of the bittersweet tragedy
of this whole show is that everything
doesn't get a happy ending and in fact
very rarely does anyone i mean i guess
jesse kind of gets a happy ending but he
has to relocate and then gene being kind
of isolated and oppressed in that sense
so i'm not entirely sure i mean i i
think a lot of people will remember
howard for who he was and not how he was
in in his final few moments um
i don't think that it'll permanently
taint his reputation overall but
it definitely left an impact as far as
people's perspectives on him and it does
really suck that he's not able to sort
of justify it or come back from it or
land on his feet so to speak so his
reputation and legacy is tainted but i
at the same time i don't think it's
completely ruined
yeah i can see what you're saying eric
i don't think he's going to get a
redemption and i honestly think if we
even see it which we probably won't i
think you'll see probably like a for
sale sign or for rent in front of hhm i
think it's done
i think i mean it was done with chuck
when chuck left that was just you know
when when howard basically paid him out
of his own pocket just you know to
basically have him away um that was the
start of the demise right there um and
with this now there's there's nothing
left there's and i don't think he's
going to get his redemption that's and
it's sad to see because i know a lot of
us you know we didn't necessarily love
howard we love the actor we love the
actor that played him but um you know
he's just that little thorn in all of
our sides and then we see him gone and
it's like it's one of the most painful
things to
to try to cope with but i don't think
he's going to get a redemption and i
think you're going to see that place
fold there's going to be a lot of
lawyers looking for work
yeah yeah i i agree that the you know he
was the last uh of the letters the hhm
letter standing and when you knock that
that down there's really nothing
there you know it's it it
nobody was was really
there to step in and kind of manage that
you know he did that on some levels for
for chuck um he was there to to kind of
you know
you know kind of keep his legacy around
to to a certain extent even though you
know he was the one that forced them out
there's really no one to do that for
howard even his wife is is indifferent
you know to the to their they've kind of
they definitely look like they've
drifted apart so um there's really no
one in howard's corner at this point
which yeah like you like you both said
it really that's the tragedy
mg
thank you for the five dollars thinking
about
clue
keep eye on stopper that's uh referring
to peter gould saying to keep an eye on
the
zafiro and
stop her from the bottle
with warning it's sharp in season 606
could it be weapon kim uses to kill lalo
forcing her to disappear
uh it could be um you know that that
would definitely
be a way to
get rid of lalo
um
i i had a lot of comments about that
it's sharp warning and and it definitely
it definitely felt intentional to to
quite a few people that they they said
that for a reason
i don't know i mean i i guess i was
thinking about the fact that you know
they're playing with fire a little bit
with this with this plan and he doesn't
get to buy the bottle at the end because
of the fact that you know some something
went wrong and and then you have
domino's fall and that ends with
howard leading out on the carpet um
what do you think eric do you think that
this is a uh
that maybe kim might use the stopper to
take out lalo
i don't know i i i don't want to say
this i don't want to get flamed for
saying this but i don't think we're
gonna see lalo die i just don't and i
know people can say he has to die in
this but i mean he he could be gone and
whether he's dead or alive we don't know
i think he's going to be gone but i
don't think he's going to die and maybe
um i always look to chase for the expert
this was theories but
maybe what we saw with the the stopper
rolling out of the back of the truck
when you know the feds and whoever was
the movers were confiscating all the
stuff from saul's house we saw the
stopper roll out i mean i wonder if that
is
that's that's it maybe that's the last
we see of that thing i don't know um but
they they are known for throwing us uh
some some misdirection sometimes maybe
that's the last of the the stopper that
we're supposed to watch for i don't know
yeah okay and we will we will come back
around to that idea about that that's
one of the things i wanted to talk about
whether he could survive or not so so
we'll we'll put a pin in that one until
later go ahead chase
uh yeah i mean that would be a crazy
misdirect i don't think came out of as a
murderer but that could be one of the
big surprises it could be a reason as to
why she disappears or why she's not in
breaking bad i always thought that the
601 bottle stopper was just kind of to
signify kim's uh u-turn into bad choice
road and i don't even think it's so much
uh implies that kim is still living with
jimmy or saul just that he keeps that
around uh just as a reminder of his time
with her uh but i mean if that sort of
you know uh it's sharp watch out for it
if that sort of implication does come
back around i think that would be crazy
that would be a crazy misdirect to see
kim kill wallow i haven't really thought
about that my main theory is that mike
is going to end up killing wallow
somehow
but i i guess we'll uh talk more about
that in a little bit
i mean one thing that they have
definitely
made clear abundantly clear throughout
the series is what a physical force
lalo is i mean just in the last his last
interaction with casper
he was hit in the back with
by a full-grown man with the back of an
axe and he still managed to get the
upper hand so it would be uh you know it
would be no small feat for her to be
able to
uh take him out with that but i you know
i i don't i don't imagine that i mean i
i definitely think they could pull that
off if they if that's where they wanted
to go with it they could write that in a
way that you would be like holy hell
what just happened
uh big mac 076 thank you for the 499.
i'm wondering what you guys thoughts and
our
thoughts and predictions are on the 405
cold open that's the quite a ride um
flash forward
who's calling at 3 p.m
on jimmy's birthday and who is
francesco's attorney well i've always
thought it was kim who was calling at 3
p.m
there are you know other things that you
could make but it seems like the closer
we get to this actually happening the
the
there aren't more options they just seem
to be getting narrow as far as like
francesca there was always the idea that
maybe she was going to call hhm that's
not going to happen anymore so i don't
even know who it could be it could be
aaron brill it could be uh cliff maine
you know i mean like i imagine it's
someone that we have already met in the
story but um
that's a little bit more of a mystery
now i i definitely do think it's kim
who's calling uh on his birthday
what do you think chase
well well the thing is if it is kim i
don't really think that jimmy needs to
say to francesca tell him jimmy sent you
because i mean kim knows jimmy well
enough even as saul goodman that i don't
really think that she needs that sort of
introduction uh yeah my my main guess
was howard obviously that's not the case
anymore i don't think it's gonna be some
random character like aaron or bill
oakley but on the other hand i do think
it could be
uh rich or cliff but they always seem to
be on the straight and narrow i don't
really know if they're going to
defend francesca or something like that
i believe suzanne erickson becomes the
head of the heisenberg case by the time
el camino rolls around so it can't be
her so yeah i'm really really left uh
scratching my head in regards to that
honestly
yeah my interpretation of that's
different the way that i i look at that
scene is that there's two different
things that he's talking about he he he
he's talking about a call that's going
to be at 3 p.m he doesn't give her any
additional information about but then he
also hands her a card which you think is
for an attorney and that's who he's
talking about whenever he says tell him
jimmy sent you
i i don't think he's saying for her to
tell the person on the phone but i guess
you know it could be interpreted
different ways um eric what do you what
do you think do you want to chime in do
you think you know who's who he's
calling there um i'm possibly kim but
one thing i thought was quite exciting
when i interviewed tina parker who plays
francesca some time ago
and she talked about that scene because
fans asked that question all the time
who is it you know blah blah blah and
the card that she was given was a blank
card there's nothing written on that
card obviously so you didn't necessarily
have
the answer to that yet you know how they
do that they paint themselves in the
corners and they get in that corner okay
now who are we going to make be on the
other end of this call
um
chase you both made good
good points i mean it's not just going
to be some you know some random person
on the end of that line it's going to
have some significance because you know
saul was in sheer panic a little panic
you know make sure this call is not
missed so
whether it's enemy then again too there
was no such thing as kim yet right so
i don't know i'm leaning towards kim
wherever kim may be and i think i don't
think she's going to be in a good place
either i think she's going to be alive
but she's going to be not being a good
place and it's going to be a
time-sensitive phone call for her as
well too
um
i don't know i don't know i'd love to
hear the fan theories for sure
yeah and that's a great point that
you're making there that um they don't
they they probably didn't know either
way
who either of those people were when
they wrote it i was listening to
whenever we talked about you coming on i
went back and listened to uh the first
interview you did with vince
and and i remember that him and tom
talking about that that they you know
that they they don't do it on purpose
but they end up writing themselves into
the corner which we know that from
watching breaking bad i mean we saw that
play out several times
and uh
you know and i just thought about that
way that they were talking about certain
events that happened and how they didn't
know
you know like it's where it seems like
it was completely
plotted the whole way out and you
realize you know they didn't know what
they were doing there they just thought
it would make a good scene if
if uh if
saul gave her you know instructions and
handed her this card and you know
they'll be able to use that later
whenever they get to
a place where they need to so yeah
that's a great that's a great thing to
keep in mind but
i i think we're pretty much in consensus
that that it will end up being kim it'll
be a real surprise if it's someone else
so it'll be good to see
justin trumbull
thank you for the 499 do you think we'll
get a howard funeral scene an
explanation for the marriage falling
apart
you three are awesome well thank you for
that um
i don't think so i don't think we'll get
a howard funeral scene i could be wrong
i mean
we'll be getting into this later but i i
feel like that
sort of what i was saying earlier about
lalo pulling everyone into his his orbit
here
i kind of feel like a lot of the bcs
stuff is
where we're
not that there's not a lot of stuff that
we have to touch on and that that they
will but i feel like a lot of it is
we're kind of we're kind of being pulled
into um
the breaking bad
story now and you know of course kim is
so
entwined with with jimmy that she's on
on the ride there
but you know
like i said we'll talk about this a
little bit more because you know we have
six episodes to go we have to we we have
to definitively figure out what's going
on with the situation that's that
they're in right now and how
gus versus lalo goes
and then you know
we have to do we have to visit jean so
you know we have we have a lot of stuff
to do and not a lot of episodes so i i
tend to think that we're going to get
less of filling in the blanks about
things from the bcs timeline and more
about
blending the two series together
did either of you guys have something
you want to
add to that well i think for sure with
not seeing any more of howard i think if
we see any more of howard we may see
possibly just just a corpse in the eyes
of mike or whoever there is going to
clean it up and the reason why i say
that
someone had asked tom the other night
when he was on with me with um with
louis and danny they asked about him
falling howard falling and hitting his
head so tom wrote that in as well too to
just make the worst even more
bad horrific sweet shot in the head he
falls it hits his head
i i think if we had a funeral that's
going to give a little bit of closure
and it's you know okay we're done with
that so
that terrific
horrific not terrific horrific scene uh
being shot and falling and then to
accent that pain by seeing a dead body
maybe that might be the last we'll see
if howard i don't think they're gonna do
a funeral and make it kind of okay we
can get past this now so i don't think
we'll see that
i mean if we do see a funeral it all
depends on whether or not howard's body
is found i mean do they stage it as a
suicide do they stage it as an accident
do they just completely disappear his
body and leave him missing do they frame
him for taking a trip to belize and
never coming back i think it really
depends on what happens to the body but
also i don't really think that they want
to
kind of do the same thing that they did
with chuck like we had a funeral scene
with chuck um so regardless if we see a
funeral scene for howard or not i mean i
guess obviously they could still do a
funeral scene even if they don't see the
body but i would like to see how cheryl
his wife reacts to it if she truly does
show remorse and is you know crying and
super sad or if she's overall just jaded
to the fact that howard's gone i think
that would be an interesting scene to
see especially if she's talking to cliff
about it or even for some reason jimmy
or kim not sure why they would ever meet
up but it could kind of call back to the
whole rebecca going to see jimmy and kim
chuck's ex-wife back in season three i
believe so yeah i'm not too sure just
depends what happens to the body but i
would like to see some sort of uh howard
and chuck flashback uh before the show's
over i think that'd be great
good yes i think something like that
would be uh more fitting than just
spending a lot of time in the current
timeline sorry here go ahead no no no i
just agreeing totally totally green
yeah
tenor r thank you for the 4.99 uh this
is kind of a general question so um he
says do you guys have any criticisms for
bcs now that we're approaching the end
um i think you know i like i said it's
general and i don't want to i don't want
to go down uh
a completely different road than where
where we're the direction we're heading
right now but i i would just say like
for me the
i don't think that my criticisms for bcs
have changed that much over the years um
i think in the beginning i i thought at
times it could be a little bit indulgent
in in certain things i think that
there's
stuff that they do where they're really
um
focused in on the process of
of a character doing something and
whatever they're doing will
uh you know it'll explain to us where
they're at what they're thinking about
what they're what they're going to do
and they're not talking to anyone so we
have to actually watch them do this
thing and it works really well to
develop the characters but at times
you're just sort of like okay did we
have to watch 10 minutes of mike doing
that thing you know what i mean and um
and you know and like those are those
are just sort of
experiences are those things that i
experience when i'm watching but i think
almost always that it's worth it in the
end like i don't think that there's
anything that that i that i absolutely
just don't enjoy about the show i mean i
enjoy the characters and you know you
kind of need all of that stuff to make
them as enjoyable as they are so
do you guys want to add anything here
um well as far as being a little bit too
self-indulgent i definitely agree with
that um you know this show has masterful
cinematography and all that mainly just
because the people working on the show
have all the experience of breaking bad
you know on their belt uh but i would
really have to kind of uh stretch and
search for any any true criticisms uh
for this show like in regards to i think
it was uh the beginning of season three
watching mike tear his car apart to find
uh the tracker and the gas cap i know
there were some complaints about that
but i genuinely enjoyed that whole thing
uh relating back to the most current
season seeing the slide rule getting
cased in the acrylic maybe that was a
little bit too much self-indulgence i i
like the whole mystery aspect of it but
they have done that quite a few times
this season where they show oh what's
with the security cameras at the
beginning and then we find that out or
what's with the blue flower and then we
find that out by the end of the episode
so i feel like they may have done that
one too many times this season i don't i
don't really think that the pacing of
the show was uh too slow i've heard uh
you know a handful of complaints about
um you know episodes 604 to 606 being
too slow really i i feel like maybe one
of the episodes was a little bit too
slow but i i enjoyed the rest of it um i
guess one of the only things that kind
of made me feel a little bit off put and
i was talking to pete about this behind
the scenes a little bit is that we just
didn't really get much of the aftermath
of nacho's death i would have liked to
see i think i've said this
sorry i think i've said this before even
on peach stream but i would have liked
to see mike sort of go back and bury
nacho's body where the blue flower grows
or or see a little bit more about mike's
father but it you know aside from the
one time that pete pointed out to me
that uh mike mentions nacho's father's
place to tyrus and i think 605 or 606 we
haven't really heard anything about
nacho or the aftermath and i i would
have liked to see more about how that
affects mike and kind of his
de-evolution into no half-measures
that's about it
you have anything you want to add eric
sure i agree with chase on two things
here uh number one too with nacho i mean
people could say you know howard was
just as much of a powerful character
being in from the very first season as
well too like like nacho was but nacho
his character was that that good guy
that wants to get out and i think he
deserved a bit more uh story to be told
maybe after his death so i would like to
see that we might still you know we
might see a little bit more it would be
very nice and i also like that chase
brought up the fact about um
mike and the gas cap and one thing i
think it was good and bad at the same
time about that the bad was how long it
took to you know to go through that but
it could be a long long and painful
scene
but i think what the writers were trying
to show there was just like gus spring
hides in plain sight your enemies hiding
in plain sight that that tracker was in
plain sight mike pretty much destroyed
that car and you know like it's almost
like doing tech support for someone you
do tech support with someone and you're
like i'm not getting any sound from my
speakers so did you check your drive to
check this check this meanwhile it's not
plugged into the darn wall
so
it's the simplest of things sometimes
and it took a long time in that gas cap
scene to figure out what it was but the
the moral of that story was
um and i think it paid off was that
things are in plain sight sometimes so
and i think we've seen that a lot in in
the breaking bad in the gilliverse world
you know and better cross all both
everything it's the things we're hiding
in plain sight and i love that
yeah like i said i think that almost all
like you know sometimes you should be a
little bit uncomfortable when you're
watching i think too like i think about
the early parts of season four were
they they made they had jimmy making
some decisions that were just really
hard to understand and that can be
frustrating you know and i guess in the
beginning of season six it's the same
way like they they obscured a lot of the
plan for us in a way that they don't
usually do you know what i mean there
was a lot of us guessing what what was
going to have happened
and i you know it made me a little bit
uncomfortable but whenever you know
you see the whole picture at the end i
don't i don't think any of it is is too
out of place and um
no even even jimmy working in the cell
phone in the cell phone shop you know
like i mean some of that was long and
drawn out you know it was boring
sometimes like i mean
yeah i mean not boring for us as viewers
boring for jimmy you know like okay
but we look back at that now and what
might have seemed like 10 15 minutes of
that in a particular episode it's gone
like this because now we see what it's
done and it's become an integral part of
him now
yeah and that's that's what that's what
kind of hits you later in that in that
season is you're like
jimmy doesn't know what he jimmy jimmy's
doing weird stuff that doesn't make
sense because he doesn't know what's
going on like he it's because he is
in this traumatic you know he's got ptsd
from his brother dying so he of course
he's doing weird things that don't make
sense because he doesn't know what's
going on with him you know what i mean
it just takes a little bit you have to
get through all of that to understand it
whenever you know the payoff comes i
guess you know
the judo joker thank you for ten dollars
thoughts on kim going even darker in 6b
and her potentially sending the cab
driver after jean
also want to shout out a growing bcs
youtuber courtney reviews she'd make a
great future guest here
um i've seen a couple people mention
this person courtney reviews um i was
telling eric right before we came on i
don't watch a lot of um
videos about stuff that i cover because
i don't want other people's
thoughts and views uh seeping into
whatever i'm working on so
uh you know i've never seen
a courtney
reviews video and um
i don't i don't know who who they are so
um maybe you know maybe that's something
to think about in the future but
as of right now
it's not it's i don't really know what
uh what to say about that um but
thoughts on kim going even darker in 6b
i think for me
kim is in survival mode and that that
could definitely
involve getting darker um
they're they're in a place where they
have to react to what's happening to
lalo now you know i mean they don't
really they're not really pulling the
strings
you know they're not they're she was
driving things in the first part of six
and and she's not in the driver's seat
anymore now now lala salamanca is so
i feel like most of what she's going to
do is going to be directly related to
her survival and getting out of the
situation that they found themselves in
because of this ill-advised
thing that they did against howard
her potentially sending the cab driver
after gene
that's not a that's not a theory i've
ever connected with or thought made any
kind of sense
i know a lot of people
are looking for something like that
there to me gene
or the cab driver jeff he always seemed
like a random albuquerque person
possibly in the same way that we're
talking about before that the writers
didn't know exactly why that was gonna
you know what what was gonna come of him
being there but they wanted to you know
make that connection with somebody who
knew who knew who uh gene was and um
i guess they could go back after the
fact and say that someone sent sent him
uh that the
the air freshener being in the courtroom
kind of makes you think that those two
things might be connected but
i'm not i'm not there yet um
what about you chase
uh well first in regards to kim going
darker and 6b i think there's one of
two options here either one she could
you know sort of take a backseat and let
jimmy handle things since he's more
used to the whole cartel side of things
even though kim is built of sterner
stuff i feel like she has gone a little
in over her head in regards to
lalo with uh going and seeing him when
lala was in jail and then standing up to
lalo in 509 even though we know it did
work and wallow did back down uh this
time he's he's not really going to so
i'm not i'm not too sure if she's going
to take a backseat and kind of let
jimmy evolve into saul and let him take
care of things or if she's just going to
completely double down and maybe it
could end up with her losing her life
because of still being too in over her
head and uh in regards to the cab driver
i mean it seems like we're always trying
to find connections to the cab driver
like who sent the cab driver after gene
was it kim is lalo still alive did he
send the cab driver after gene uh i mean
these are all theories that are
possibilities i'm not gonna say i'm
against them in any way shape or form
but i do just kind of believe that jeff
is on his own i
but that being said i am curious what
the deal with the izotope air freshener
is uh seeing that in season six when uh
cliff was watching kim in the courtroom
i don't know if that has any sort of
connection or if it's just sort of an
easter egg for uh vivid viewers i guess
but yeah i feel like jeff the cab driver
is just kind of on his own almost like a
wannabe criminal that uh maybe sees gene
as sort of possibly his connection into
the underworld or might want to extort
him for some reason but i don't really
think that anyone is controlling jeff or
anything like that but i guess we'll
have to wait and see
yeah eric
well i think with the air freshener and
things like that as well too just from
the other night too talking with tom
like tom kind of debunks so many things
like sometimes fans really want to take
these two pieces and put them together
because they seem so similar and i'm not
just talking about the air freshener i'm
talking about anything like a number on
a on a domino means this person is going
to die in this episode or something like
that and like they proved that it's just
it's not it's not the way it is and tom
will even say that's cool that's an
awesome theory i wish i would have
thought of that sometimes the writers
even wish they thought of those things
but it's just not the case and it's more
often than not so now i'm starting to
even if i think of these ideas and they
can no that would they wouldn't do that
i just they wouldn't do that so i'm not
falling into that i don't think that has
anything to do with it i don't know
where he's coming from jeff
um but as far as kim going darker i
think we might possibly um we might
possibly be at her darkest rate now
because we've got this body we've got to
deal with um she might go on the hook
for it um maybe her and jimmy both do i
don't know she may disappear
witness relocation you know disappearing
whatever but something that's really
struck me weird about her for quite some
time
is she seemed overly overly anxious to
help jimmy get to the sandpiper
settlement she you know and even jimmy
was kind of like
a couple times right and she really
wants that money um is she gonna take
the money and run um i don't know but
she was a little overly anxious to get
that uh settlement whether it be for
jimmy or for ulterior motive motives
i i just want to kind of wanted to add
quickly to the whole tom debunking stuff
i i did know i think it was a tweet that
he even said about the dominoes uh about
nacho with the 603 and there's a lot of
connections in this show that maybe the
creators didn't initially intend but
viewers find and i've heard in
interviews with peter and
vince saying that they they enjoy us
interpreting it in different ways so
even if it's not something they
originally intended uh it's still nice
to see these connections um such as in
the one of the recent insider podcasts
uh lalo you know being in the sewers
kind of reminding of us of pennywise
from it uh apparently that wasn't
intentional but they you know they got a
good laugh out of it so i think it's
fair to say that they approve of some
things even if they're even if they're
not completely intentional
well in the grand scheme of things it's
like going to starbucks and and i go to
starbucks i get a coffee and they say
they put derrick on the cup i'm like hey
my name's eric so i take a picture of
and i tweet it i'm talking look what
starbucks did we're we're talking about
our coffee now in this case we know
we're talking about fan theories it's
top of mind is keeping the show relevant
you know so i mean of course they're
loving it
um
yeah yeah and um
i think
we're gonna touch on a little bit more
of that stuff as we go on so i i don't
want to stick here too long but um
the the idea of
her
i mean the opposite idea is also
something that we we need to consider
that
she she has she has a choice where she
can go darker or or she can get out
which is sort of what you know you both
touched on a little bit there
and um
i think what's fun is that both things
are almost equally possible you know one
doesn't really like
win the day
instantly you know so it's it's a it's a
complicated character and you know you
can't really
nail anything down because there's
there's so many different ways they can
go
mike garabani thank you for the 555
swiss francs
how can saul and kim get away with
howard's murder i mean that's a good
question
the he says the police will inevitably
figure out his car was in their
apartment
lot as he disappears well yeah and i
think the important thing to to consider
here is that nobody
nobody is prepared for this uh i i don't
i mean lalo he came in uh
to talk to them
he found out that he was there one of
those things that tom
kind of
uh shot down that you were just talking
about eric was that he he didn't he
didn't hear something that they were
talking about and then decide to kill
howard this was just the the the purest
thing of being in the wrong place at the
wrong time you know he he came in
with a with
to do something and
howard was there and he you know he had
to go and i don't think in that scenario
and i talked about this in my last video
i i don't think in that scenario he
really cares
what happens to howard because
he wants to find something out from from
jimmy and kim
and
really
they die after that's over you know i
mean like that that should be the end of
them as well so he can just leave three
dead bodies in that apartment and leave
and never return you know as it just
remain a ghost
that that where it gets you know
interesting and and
kind of what
one of the things i want to talk about
today was that you know
we know jimmy survives you know i mean
you know he becomes saul goodman so
he's gonna have to do something
that as a team they're gonna have to do
something that they're you know to make
themselves valuable to him
and that's kind of the whole idea of how
they're going to get away with it is
sort of secondary to that i mean we we
know for sure that that jimmy does we
know that for sure that he is
you know doesn't lose his license he's
still practicing law you know four years
later so
you know i guess for me i i i
i'm not sure the specifics on how they
do it i just sort of trust the writers
know how to make that make sense and
i'm not really concerned that they won't
be able to do that
what do you think about that eric like
do you think that this is a big sticking
point the fact that there's a dead body
here that they're going to get caught
for
i don't i think because we've we've seen
it a million times now how they can i
can can fix that but i think it can be a
breaking point for kim i i i'm going to
go with the theory that i don't think
are going to see kim go darker i think
that was a wake-up call for her like wow
we've actually now at their fingertips
have had someone die
um that will happen many times in in
saul's lifetime but this is probably the
first time that kim has experienced it
and maybe the last so i don't think
we're going to go darker i don't think
it's going to be much of a problem
for them to take care of the body and i
i i'm surprised the way that we've had
death is uh as fast and um extreme as
we've had in this season
with uh with nacho and howard i don't
think we're going to see a lot more
death i i might personally go on the
record to say i think that we'll see kim
go somewhere um hiding whatever and i
don't think we're going to find out what
happens to lalo
i mean i know a lot of fans want to see
some big action and and some definitive
answers but sometimes not knowing is the
best story so yeah that's that's my
answer to that
um i i just kind of wanted to uh touch
on the whole plot armor of it all real
quick because just the fact that jimmy
does have this plot armor makes it makes
me really focus on kim and what her fate
will be if lala's going to kill her but
at the same time i'm still worried for
jimmy because just relating back to
season 5 with bagman we knew that jimmy
and mike had to survive those events but
in my opinion it didn't make that
episode any less intense so even with
breaking bad characters having this plot
armor uh the creators still do a really
good job at making me uh scared for them
and wonder what's to happen to them so
i'm really curious curious on how
they're going to get out of this
situation first off and then how they're
going to possibly take care of howard's
body
yeah yeah i i think like i said i i
haven't put a lot of thought into it
because i know that they'll they'll
they'll they'll give us something that
makes sense um but
i am interested to see how it plays out
sue's bart
b art maybe 499 thank you again
kim's dad in prison kim's mom in prison
kim in prison
the wechsler family prison um
yeah i mean they
that was that was definitely one of the
most popular theories before
when murder entered the uh
the equation
it it felt less likely um
i i had meant to make a video about this
a couple weeks ago but i didn't get
around to it uh you know they they
if it seems like it's weird because
i feel like in the events that have
happened in the last couple of episodes
i feel more
certain that that kim will survive like
that there's really no threat to her
life
but at the same time
it almost feels like that she's going to
have to run away after after howard you
know what i mean um whereas before you
thought maybe she might turn herself in
or something might happen and and and
it's just murder now so like going to
prison is like a forever kind of thing
not not
uh you know a few years to to through
your time and then get out and meet up
with jimmy on the outside again
what do you what do you guys think about
the the wechsler family as a bunch of
jail birds
uh well
i i think that kim and her dad are just
sort of estranged i think there's a
reason why we've never really seen
anything maybe they you know hung out at
when kim was of a young age but that she
didn't really see much of him in his
teen years i'm not too sure if uh
her dad and her mom are even together i
think it would make more sense if they
weren't considering that it's kind of
implied that maybe kim's mom was looking
after kim on her own uh my leading
theory for kim's mom is that she
eventually got in a drunk driving car
accident and died but it is possible
that she could have been sent to prison
for conning or stealing she finally got
caught for that and that could have been
what uh sent kim on the straight and
narrow made her move to albuquerque
become a lawyer and then as far as uh
kim being in jail um
i i do think i have thought that kim
being disbarred is and losing her job
and maybe going to jail is a more tragic
fate for her than just dying because if
she dies like yeah that would be really
shocking if lalo killed her at the
beginning of the next episode but it
would kind of be an injustice to her
character in regards to i think the more
tragic option is if she gets disbarred
she loses her job and her dream of
working with pro bono clients and then
she goes to jail so that she can't even
spend the money that she got from
sandpiper uh tom schnauz mentioned in a
hollywood reporter kind of article
interview that one of the main ideas for
607 was kim getting disbarred but it
didn't feel right so i don't know if
that means that they're not going to go
with that at all or if that just means
they're not going to go with that yet
but yeah those are my thoughts
you got anything you want to add to that
eric uh very good observations and i do
think that maybe
um the death of the mom could be could
be something as well too i mean you know
we saw that she'd like to have for
taking the drink uh even when she'd have
her child in the car so i mean you know
she could be gone um i do think that we
may still see um kim disbarred in jail
um
because that she she puts up she might
be she may be weak behind the scenes and
she puts on the strong front that she
has everything together and the law is
the only thing that maybe keeps that
glue and her sanity together and without
that agreed that could be more
punishment than um than being killed you
know it's a lifetime of of uh punishment
and i i feel strongly that we may see
something like that she may be on the
run or maybe uh maybe running from the
law for for several episodes and then
caught uh towards the end and spends the
rest of her life in jail
yeah i i um one of the things that that
i thought about whenever they did the
second
flashback to her or the yeah the
flashback to her childhood was
the idea about her running you know i
mean she she ran away from
from uh where she came from because she
she didn't like it there and we we got a
glimpse into part of the reason you know
that is how that's related to her mother
and it you know it just seems like
there's always that idea that she might
go back to omaha like that it's
important that he's there because of
that and i every time i hear that i just
think there's really nothing that would
would take her there you know what i
mean like what it could be her mother i
guess but
um
it seems more like a coincidence that
he's in the same place she came from as
in that she might just end up back there
because she thinks it's a nice place it
to me it seems more like she would just
run somewhere different you know usually
if you're if you're running away from
somewhere and you get to the next place
and it's not
what you hoped it would be or if you end
up you know being caught up in a
homicide and you have to to run away to
somewhere else you don't necessarily go
backwards you go to the next place you
know what i mean
so yeah that
that that's sort of what i had been
thinking about as far as her you know
what we were thinking about her as
someone who runs away then she'll she'll
probably run somewhere different not
back home you know i can if i can argue
one point though just it just struck me
like maybe
on the flip side of that look at the
kettleman's you know they stayed close
to home they were supposedly kidnapped
after they ran away and they stayed
close to homer is safe maybe that might
and i i don't think this but i'm just
trying to hypothesize her a little bit
maybe kim being back home might be
safe for her just a thought yeah
yeah i don't i don't think that kim will
go like exactly back to red cloud which
is the small town that she's from but it
is possible that she could be somewhere
near there and the whole thing about uh
gene being sent there is that uh he
didn't come up with the location it was
ed it was purely coincidental so
i'm not sure if there's any connection
there um and again about jeff i don't
think that kim you know got jeff to go
and go and hunt down gene but i think
that gene might
try to get in contact with kim in order
to help with jeff if you know she's
still alive obviously
yeah oh yeah definitely that um
reconyx 146 thank you for the ten
dollars did you hear the theory about
the diamonds in the gene timeline they
could be the seven million dollars bail
money
jimmy was entitled to after it was made
public that lalo was dead um
yeah i don't know i'm not a lawyer i
don't really know how that would work i
don't think that jimmy's gonna get seven
million dollars
in bail if if lalo doesn't show up um
that could be possible but i don't
really that doesn't really make sense to
me he it's not his money he didn't post
it um
they would i think they would look for a
next to ken or something if he was
actually entitled to get it back but i
don't know because i'm not a lawyer uh
the diamonds thing is
is a um
you know i i i hope that we actually get
a scene that that shows us how those uh
came about but um
i don't know the theory i mean i've
heard different theories about the
diamonds so i'm not sure what the
specific theory that that we're talking
about here i don't think it's seven
million dollars worth of diamonds that
he's held on to since
uh this this time period but i could be
wrong about that
what do you think uh
do you know the actual theory he's
referring to here or they're referring
to here
i'm not not too sure no i don't i don't
think the diamonds are because of the
seven million dollars in bail money um
and i don't know i like i did a video
about the diamonds like two years ago so
i'd honestly have to or you know refresh
myself on on what i even thought about
it back then compared to now because
just so much has happened but we do know
that the diamonds are in the band-aid
box which is in the shoe box which was
uh behind the wall of saul's office
during breaking bad so
it's it's implied that
saul put that box there before cause uh
in better call saul's season six we know
he has his office but it looks very much
different due to francesca trying to
decorate it so it whenever saul changes
the decorations and puts up those
pillars um and changes his office to
look like what we know in breaking bad
uh he must have the diamonds by that
point so it is possible that we could
see him get the diamonds by the end of
the series
and the diamonds something as simple as
just a payment from somebody as well too
it could be something completely like
we're putting so much focus on them it
could just be a payment
yeah i i agree with that as well and i
think they probably will you know like i
said explain where they came from but i
don't i don't i haven't heard any great
theories that just
just made so much sense to me that you
know that i that i
was following it or whatever
um keith
gatchell thank you for the five dollars
appreciate that
uh thomas cunningham thank you for the
4.99 hey guys love all the channels and
consistent content do you think we'll
see lalo acknowledge nacho betrayed him
move a great question
yeah i
i think that
well i think that nacho is the thing
that brings him back to jimmy and kim's
house in in a way you know i mean
because
he realizes that nacho introduced him to
to saul in the first place when he
needed a lawyer so
uh
do i think he'll acknowledge it i mean i
think he knows it um
you said it was a great cr
a question chase what is what are you uh
what are you getting here that i'm not
because i mean i i don't understand what
he's saying but i acknowledge like
acknowledge to who
uh i i think he might acknowledge it to
jimmy and kim and i think that would be
something in regards to lalo talking
about nachos since we never saw a lalo
versus nacho confrontation post
assassination attempts
and i do think you're right that it's
kind of what i was thinking of too in
regards to nacho being the one that even
introduced lalo to jimmy in the first
place and told them about the whole tuko
encounter because if lalo thinks that
nacho was working for gus or gus was
involved then who else was involved with
nachos skiing could jimmy know and
that's kind of you know what lalo's plan
will be in regards to the next episode
is the fact that jimmy knows nacho jimmy
knows mike how much does he know
about what they did because um you know
mike was the one that put lollo in jail
in the first place and then mike was the
one that went to jimmy to get lalo out
of jail and and mike was the one that
was in the desert with jimmy so it just
depends how much you know this down this
rabbit hole that lala will take them but
i do think that nacho knowing jimmy is
one of the main connections that got
lalo to go back to him so i'm really
curious to see if lala will acknowledge
nacho and what he truly thinks about him
since we never got a lalo nacho
confrontation
yeah i mean they they mentioned it i
mean the cartel definitely thought that
nacho was the rat and was behind it all
and it's it's apparent that that
you know lala would have the same
uh same conclusion and and he knows that
gus is behind it so
that connects those people and like you
said you know jimmy then is connected to
gus even if he doesn't know gus or or or
why he ended up in the middle of it all
that that seems to be the most
plausible reason why he would go back
there you know what i mean why lala
would go back to their house eric did
you have something you wanted to add to
this one
no i just think that's why lalo's back
in the apartment right now for two
reasons one to finally let's see let's
hear the story the real story finally uh
because kim interrupted jimmy when he
was trying to tell the story the last
time
and so i think he's there for that and
he's also the connection between jimmy
was working with nacho as his lawyer
there's there's a lot of unanswered
questions with nacho and uh um
and also what happened in that desert so
that's the first and foremost and now on
top of all that you got a dead body now
right beside them and that doesn't help
any negotiations uh go smoothly
whatsoever so
yeah and the taco truck engineer thank
you for the 4.99 this just hit me
stopper fell in the storm dream lala was
in storm drain connection between lalo
and kim
well they're connected in the fact that
they're in that house together like we
just said and uh
there's a dead body between them um i i
don't think i know and there's there are
theories out there that
that i see in the comments that i i
don't really pay a lot of attention to i
guess um
that
uh that there's some connection between
kim and lalo that we've not seen yet it
doesn't seem to to play out i don't know
if it's just for fun kind of thing you
know what i mean but um
that is a nice connection there between
the the stopper falling in the drain
and the fact that he was there
um
astro 1980 thank you for the five
dollars the best way to use walt would
be to have more scenes with saul and
ed's basement before they leave this
time from more of saul's perspective
this is something i've thought about
before i mentioned it in videos or on
the stream um
that's a cool amount of time where they
do have a
you know they spent more than
more than one whole day in there so
there there could be some interesting
stuff but it's the same thing it's sort
of like how does that change the story
as far as like what we know about him
like we could maybe find out something
about what's going on
with gene you know something that that's
in gene's mind that we didn't know
before that might paint those scenes
different i mean i think it's a pretty
cool idea
um
do you want to chime in on that one i i
just want to agree that
i just want to agree that i think this
is one of my favorite uh theories for
seeing more of walt um
sorry excuse me
um
in regards to the whole uh breaking bad
flash forward theories um i mean i did
like a 50 minute video thinking of every
single possible walton jessie cameo that
we could think of and and this is one of
my absolute favorites i think that we
should see more of walt and saul
together after the point that uh he saul
arrives at ed's store but before the
point that we get that conversation
where uh we have walt saying oh it's
over when i say it's over for the second
time to saul and then he coughs and kind
of has to lie down and saul says oh it's
over and then he walks away and that's
the last they ever see
there's a little bit of time in between
there that i would love it would be
perfect to just get more dialogue
between them so if we do or when we do
get a walt cameo i would love it to be
that the only thing is that um we're
confirmed to see jesse as well so i
don't know if that means we're gonna get
two separate cameos two separate flash
forwards or what but as far as just walt
goes like that is one that i'm very
excited to potentially see
you want to add something there eric um
i agree with that it's a heck of a lot
better than watching uh you know walt
wash someone's car you know what i mean
so yeah
yeah that's the that's the least
interesting theory i mean i get where
people come from when they think you
know hey okay well that would be uh yeah
that's the thing we know about the about
the show and wouldn't that be funny to
see him in the background
but um when you really think it through
there's there's a lot of better ways
that they could tie the two series
together i think
um dion thompson divoli
thank you for the 499. thanks for the
content really enjoying it yeah no
problem uh we like making it or i can't
speak for everyone here but
i i think it's safe to say that we all
like making it and we like to engage
with you know the the content that these
guys make because there's just uh so
much to talk about
j dubs center thank you for the five
dollars a couple dark horse predictions
for the francesca phone call if it isn't
kim
kooby or ornesta ernesto
both seem like they were always on good
terms with him um
yeah that's true
neither one of them have played a big
role lately uh
qb would be pretty
uh he wouldn't mean anything to people
who watch only better call saul he
doesn't exist in the universe yet so
that would be a little bit out of the
blue and
and ernesto has he has been a friend to
jimmy but ever since he lost his job at
hhm um he hasn't really been involved in
the story do you guys uh
you guys have anything on this
i can't see being either of them
good good theory that was good
yeah yeah yeah i don't really see it
being either of them but i i do want to
see some sort of ernesto cameo i'm not
sure how but i i would love to see a
little bit more of him before the show's
over
maybe he got a job at the at the car
wash afterwards and and that's how that
all gets tied together i have a feeling
he's going to head up the mail room he's
going to he's going to own that mailroom
if hhm is still a thing
yeah uh thomas cummingham thank you
again for 4.99 also thoughts on final
chuck flashback is there any aspect of
he and jimmy's relationship that could
be further explored thanks guys
i would like i kind of i mean i would
love to see
michael mckean come back i mean
obviously um
i don't think we're going to though
i think if we were going to see another
one from
them it might be interesting to me on on
a just the sort of understanding the
story part of it like
him and and
and jimmy and chuck as children
um
you know like maybe a bit further in the
timeline than when we saw the you know
the the one that was in lantern
something to see something like
foundational to how they were because i
mean
chuck had it in his mind for a long time
that that jimmy ripped off their father
and that was the original sin that he
could never make up for he doesn't ever
really talk about it in those terms but
i think that that's that's you know
that's pretty heavily implied throughout
things
and you know that was the idea that he
had was that you were born bad you've
always been bad and you always will be
like you will never change and um
so i think it would be
if if we were going to see a little bit
more of jimmy and chuck i would i would
like to see it back then
um what do you guys think
eric what do you think about that one
i'd love to see more chuck but i think
we probably did see the last one and and
kind of in the most powerful way we saw
him you know you talked about earlier in
the courtroom there where you saw her
down the courtroom in the boardroom um
with the intern there or whatever the
new guy and you saw chuck's painting
there and and a very very pivotal scene
where howard basically loses his mind so
to speak it chuck did as well too prior
to his death um you know in
in the in the trial
and i think that was a good way for us
to see michael or for chuck the last
time on the show
setting up a scene where
very soon we're gonna see howard die um
i can't see him coming back would have
any more of an impact but i would love
to see the younger brothers again you
know it's just to see how that shaped
jimmy you know maybe you know they've
always toyed with the idea how if uh if
chuck had made his mom laugh and it
wasn't jimmy that make it made his mom
laugh we might be in a different place
today as well too
to find out what uh what made them
what happened between the relationship
between the mom and the boys um i don't
know but i think we might have seen the
last of chuck in any kind of uh
uh you know circumstance on the show
i mean i i yeah i i don't i'm not too
sure if we're ever gonna see michael
mckean again i really hope we do just
because the more and more i rewatch
better call saul i just enjoy his
character even as much as chuck
frustrates me i just really love
just his character in general and so i'm
not sure if we'll see more of him and
jimmy but in regards to the recent
events with howard a good excuse to
bring back patrick fabian as well i
would like to see some sort of flashback
with chuck and howard maybe a pre-season
one talking about their
sorry talking about their like ambitions
and everything in regards to hhm and
just a bunch of hopeful attitude type
dialogue and then just directly cut to
uh the current timeline with hhm with
the for sale sign in front of it or
something like that just to show how it
did not go at all as planned
yeah
yeah i i
though that sounds like a great idea and
but i you know whenever i'm i'm doing
this now i'm realizing it more and more
that i'm just like do we have time for
that and it's really kind of sad you
know
i think i think it'd be cool for a cold
open or something like that
no i 100 agree like i i get what you're
saying but i'm just i just have my mind
just tell my logical mind is telling me
that
you know there's just six episodes left
there's just six cold opens left is
their time you know what i mean it's
just i'm not saying about the idea about
it being good or bad or or even
plausible i'm just saying that it kind
of sucks that the frame of mind is that
the end is near you know i mean
yeah
it's a big shadow over everything is
like this thing is almost over
uh flame thrower fluff salisbury thank
you for the five dollars
thank you
thank you all for your content is there
any chance at all we get a scene with
lalo and tuko even if it's just a phone
call the fans would love it um
i think it would have to be a
phone call if we are to believe that you
know tuko is still nine months out of
getting out of jail
or you know the
it would be pretty hard to justify
keeping lalo around for that long
for him to get out
and and uh yeah i don't know how that
you would be able to do that and
if he was gonna call him he there would
have to be a good reason for that
um
which i don't
i don't see not one there's not one that
comes to mind when i'm thinking about it
um
i mean what do you guys think i mean in
regards to
tuco in season six i'd love to see your
return whether it's him still in jail
and maybe we get a skinny pete cameo as
well considering that they were kind of
celies um i i would love to see a scene
of all the salamancas together you know
hector the twins lalo tuko everyone
because we've never seen them all
together before um but you know just the
fact of i'm unsure of how long lala will
survive because they could do a time
skip to when tuko gets out of jail but
the question is will lalo already be
dead by then
yeah
absolutely
what do you think eric anything else
i'd love to see you skinny pete uh cameo
but i i charles
and a gun gone out to almost debunked
that because i mean he had pitched ideas
to the team as well too like having like
his skinny pete's dad you know somehow
being at whatever then he he would be
playing the older role of himself
um or the father whatever so i don't
think we're going to see that there's so
many things we'd love to see but
again too you said i think the most
important thing you said we've got six
episodes left and there's not a lot of
time so a lot of these things as cool as
they would be are just going to be
roadblocks for this story as it unravels
yeah that's something to do i i believe
when uh skinny peaks actor was on your
show uh eric he even said that he hadn't
gotten the call yet but uh that could
have just been a misdirect i mean just
look at
look at spider-man no way home with you
know the other spider-man saying oh we
didn't get the call we didn't get the
call like oh what was it you know was it
was it something else so you never quite
know and uh yeah i do totally agree with
you guys that there isn't a lot of time
left but this final season really seems
to be doing a victory lap in regards to
bringing back old characters but in a
way that serves the current plot and
story so it doesn't feel like filler
like cliff and rich and aaron and irene
and the kettleman's like the camera crew
they're all coming back in ways that fit
the current story so it is possible for
them to do it but it's just a matter of
if they will or not or which direction
the story will take them
yeah
agreed amber t thank you for the 420 how
do you all suspect gus becomes
breaking bad gus
lalo and gun
yeah i'll throw this one over to eric
because you said that
you're you're taking the position that
that you think that lalo
might survive
so i'm i what up what i want to the the
problem i have with that is that gus has
been so
wrapped up and so
not gus
over this entire season because of the
fact that lalo is still out there so how
do you imagine
that they get
from
from this gus to the breaking bad gus as
amber t is asking
that's a really good that's a really
good question i'm reading the question
over again a couple times um i can go
left and right here with this um because
i'm gonna go with my theory first that i
think lalo lives
so the the way they're setting that up
down in the uh underneath the lab you
know gus has to remove the cable so it's
all he has to do is a quick connect you
know some fans the electrician fans out
there i went to the extreme to even say
that it's a twist connect type thing so
the connection is still there all gus
has to do is pull that cable and the
electricity is gone so the lights are
gonna go out he's planted the gun so
he's gonna try to kill lalo there so
that on the left that could be
yes uh gus becomes a breaking bad gust
by killing lalo behave of that nature
the cold-hearted killer
or
gus uh sorry lalo escapes and we have to
find some other way where gus becomes
that killer so that that's a that's a
balance scale who knows on that one i i
still think lalo is not going to die
so gus has to come up with another way
to flip that switch to become the uh
the um cold-hearted killer that he is
uh the the only thing i want to add
about the whole uh the chekhov's gun
down in the super lab is that yeah we've
never seen gus uh kill anyone directly
with a gun whenever we do it's with his
hands whether it's the box cutter with
the bag with arturo in season four so i
think if we did see gus actually use a
gun for the first time it would be
really impactful but at the same time
i'm not sure if lalo would go out that
way that easily uh my leading theory is
still that mike will kill lalo but yeah
we'll just have to wait and see if he
survives or not with all the paranoia
that gus has had throughout season six
i'm not sure if he'll be okay to just
kind of move on with his life especially
after just now learning confirmation
that lalo is alive and his suspicions
were correct
just as quick as a quick i've just
thought about this now is it possible
that maybe gus doesn't have to kill lalo
on his own hands is mike going to be
there
can he see can he see from the cameras
down there i don't know if there's even
cameras there yet
but maybe that gun is intended for lalo
to pick up lalo's about to kill gus
and someone takes lala out is that a
possibility
yeah i'm really not sure i mean whenever
he was pacing it off and you know he had
the the place where he knew it was that
it to me it seemed like the intention
was for us to notice that he was putting
it somewhere where he would be able to
get it no matter what happens like he
was being very careful to put it
somewhere but also remember exactly
where it was at
and then you know that was a while ago
and nothing we haven't gone back there
so
it's hard to say
it's hard to say what's gonna happen
before we know where how he he planned
on that becoming important you know what
i mean like how is he thinking he's
going to get him into
into that space
you know like
him discovering it's one thing but to be
in a situation where they're in there
together
that kind of makes a lot of like you
know like does he invite him there or
does he does he let him sneak in so it's
a trap you know what i mean like there's
so many different options of what he's
thinking there that it's hard for me to
kind of put it together
well although i do think that
uh it will eventually come to fruition
it definitely was an intentional
misdirect where we thought that the
final 607 confrontation with lala was
going to go down in the super lab with
gus or mike or tyrus and then lalo ended
up going to the apartment instead so i'm
not too sure but i think it might have
been gil that said something about you
know lalo uh or sorry gus checking the
lights to see them turn on and off and
then
and then pacing towards the gun to see
how many steps he he has to take in
order to grab it um i'm not sure how
important that'll be you think you could
just run to where the you know the
construction vehicle is and and or the
bulldozer or whatever and just kind of
grab it in the heat of things and also
how are you going to really be able to
shoot someone in the dark i guess
they're already saying when we were
talking about it it's like yeah
i guess yeah yeah i remember you guys
talking about that beforehand so i'm
just really curious how that's all going
to come to fruition or if it even still
will i mean i imagine that they won't
just leave that in the air for forever
but i'm really curious how they're going
to come back to it now i don't know if
they're going to somehow trick lala to
go down there if they're going to force
them to or something like that but i
would like to see how that would come to
fruition i do think that it's a cool
idea eric had with uh lalo being the one
to actually find and find and grab the
gun but then it'll be too little too
late uh i don't know i just have to wait
and see i guess
yeah and this next one is also about the
gun uh moises
bow buena thank you for the 9.99
watching gus hiding the gun reminds me
of walter hiding the ricin
as he used it to kill lydia i wonder if
it'll be used on kim what do you guys
think so
he's saying that you know he put it
there for for one reason but it'll end
up
being used for a different reason
does that seem possible
i don't think we're going to see kim die
i don't want to see kim die
even though she has become a more
complicated character i still don't want
to see her die i understand that
yeah i don't think that kim's gonna end
up going down to the super lab for any
reason uh to be honest and uh and also
if uh if the whole kim kills lalo theory
um it i believe that jimmy still doesn't
know that lalo is dead and breaking bad
all of the it wasn't me it was ignacio
did lalo send you and you know it's
still possible to blame a dead man so he
could say it was nacho even though he
knows that he's dead but you know just
forever being in fear of lalo saying did
lalo send you um and any even if they do
kill even if mike and gus do kill lalo
and mike tells jimmy he could just
possibly have so much ptsd and trauma
that he could just never fully believe
him so
even if lalo does die by the time
breaking bad happens i don't think that
jimmy ever truly believes it or even
knows
absolutely um i just noticed the time
eric i just wanted to check in with you
i i know you said that you could
stick around for an hour and a half so
um if you're running out of time 11 to
five minutes
yeah yeah what i mean i'm just going to
say whenever you're ready just let me
know and we'll let you
plug your stuff before you go and thank
you okay yeah and i just you know you
can stay as long as you want i just
didn't want to uh keep you against your
will if you
i'd like to be a longer yeah no i
haven't it gets in the morning tomorrow
but i appreciate it so much trust me
yeah okay so uh james eagan that's a
great uh username um
if
i i thought it was jamie and james
eagan's probably your actual name yeah
so
awesome name by the way uh australian 79
799 thank you love your content guys
eric is there a chance of bob odenkirk
appearing on inside the giliburst soon
so that's directly for you okay well i'm
glad i'm able to say it here on a great
show um the answer to that is yes uh bob
will be back probably before just before
the
series finale before the very final
episode or maybe just after but um we're
going to get him uh just a while back
but you can imagine what he's doing
right now with press
interviews so it will be towards the end
of the season but we will have him back
and it might be a shorter than a 60
minute one it might be 30 minutes or or
something of that nature but yes bob
will be back for sure this year
that's awesome i think the first time
the first time you had him on you it was
a surprise uh
in peter's or something like that wasn't
it it was a prank it was it was a prank
we played melissa hi peter's assistant
and i um we played a trick on peter and
and i was able to get bob
and uh we made it look like bob was
crashing the stream and it was it was
quite funny
i remember that episode i really love
that episode everyone has to go check
that out if they haven't yet already
because there's a lot of good stuff
thank you i couldn't remember the exact
details but i i do remember that as well
yeah peter peter was peter was just as
excited as we are right now and that's
what's funny like all these people they
all everyone has heroes right we have
our heroes our heroes have heroes even
peter was kind of uh starstruck for a
moment too it was pretty cool and he
works with him every day he wrote he
wrote the show you know
that's hilarious yeah um okay tabasco
volta thank you for the five dollars my
favorite theory is that they'll use
howard's suit to move the body and car
a perfect way to take hilarious gag from
past episodes and make it dark yeah this
is a funny theory absolutely that he
just
impersonates howard um
i don't know that we're gonna see that
happen but i agree with you a hundred
percent that that is
hilarious um do you guys want to add
anything to that
i i i just want to say quick i think
that if they do do something like that
this it'll uh be in regards to framing
him going to belize like maybe jimmy
will dress up as howard drive his car to
the airport leave it there you know kind
of pretend to check through security and
then just kind of bounce out a side door
or something like that
that's good i could go with that
yeah i'm scrolling here i okay here we
go sorry uh
um that's a that's a long username that
uh thank you for the 5r
hi from brazil pete talk about the
scenes in season 6 trailer that we
haven't seen in the show yet for
instance
instance lalo with a gun looking at
gus's trailer um
oh i'm trying to think it's been a while
since i've watched the preseason trailer
and and i didn't realize there were any
scenes that
were
not
we didn't see yet
yeah i thought we how we saw every scene
the only scene i can think or the
instances in the trailer i can think of
of lalo with a gun is when he's hiding
in verner's house um that's the only
thing i can think of honestly yeah
that's the one i was thinking of too
whenever whenever he said that um
looking at gus's trailer that wasn't all
you're thinking about it was his
security guy who was doing that that
wasn't lalo now i remember it's through
the scope uh it was right before
um
they talked to nacho
how was someone protecting gus and mike
yeah it's the guy that was
i can't remember his name he's a side
character but he you know he's he's he's
a he's one we've seen he's he's one that
that has he's credited um
i can't remember the name but yeah that
wasn't that wasn't all though that was
definitely one of the security guys and
he was just sort of watching
whenever they were um you know wondering
if
basically before
they found out what happened to nacho
okay richie fobbs 9.99 thank you for
that anyone mention kim using back
service to move back to nebraska
then we get jim gene and kim scene
towards the end of the show in nebraska
um
this is something that we've answered
quite a few times and i'll just say that
we were we were talking about it earlier
maybe you heard that you know i i think
that if they do get back together in
nebraska it won't be because she ends up
there as part of escaping i think that
that'll be something that they have to
orchestrate in one way or the other
um
uh
i i it's this it's part of the reason
why that this is something i wanted to
talk about and i know you're going to be
leaving soon but
the that
kim being around in the timeline is
pretty important to the story or at
least it feels like it to me now because
if not
what is what has gene got going for him
besides this
conflict with uh
you know
with
jeff you know i mean like there has to
be something that could happen at the
end you know it's for us to anticipate
like will it or won't it right
and if you kill kim i mean even if it
was lala like say if if if your your
idea that he gets away somehow
that doesn't feel like a complete
i mean it could by the next couple of
episodes things could change but it
doesn't feel like that would be the
completion to the story at the end of it
all if he has a final showdown with lalo
in in nebraska like it almost has to be
you know this thing with kim so i i feel
like that that you know that that that
option has to be on the table almost
going into the to the end of it
what do you guys think i'll i'll say
that too i'm going to argue my own point
like i don't think kim's going to die
but you almost need to see one of those
two there's two big characters left
those two uh we obviously know jimmy's
not gonna die i saw it's not gonna die
but i mean i i almost think one of them
has to go and i know i'm being a
hypocrite when i say that because i
don't think either one of them are
um
and
i do think one has to go who is it i
don't think it's going to be kim i mean
if i i don't bet i don't gamble on
anything but i would i would like to i
would put money that kim is not going to
die um
and i guess if i was a throw a little
bit of coin to the side lala might i
don't know but somebody has to i think
i
i was just wondering if you could
elaborate on that in regards to uh
because you think kim is gonna survive
so do you think eric that she's going to
disappear do you think that she's going
to appear in the gene timeline or or
what do you think is in store for kim's
future necessarily if you have anything
in mind i think she might go into
witness relocation without doing him
like without him going to the vacuum
like just you know the disappear ed i
think she's just going to go into
witness relocation and
change her identity or she might not
even give him to that she might just run
herself and completely
change change her look change her
her whole everything about herself and
disassociate with everyone and maybe
just have that random phone call with
jimmy or
some kind of communication with him
somehow smoke signals or something i
think she might just run and um and bail
on everything
all right cool great opinions yeah
again i don't know
amber t thank you for the 420 she thinks
that kim's parents definitely went to
prison and and i think that that's about
what we were talking about before but i
i do agree that those are pop that's
possible
um
as far as kim
uh
as far as kim not being around like i
said i just feel like it it
it just it just cuts it just cuts so
much of the potential out of the end of
the of the series if she's gone because
she's she's the thing that's important
to jimmy and jimmy's the main character
of this story you know what i mean
so it's not like
any of the stuff that's related to
walter white and breaking bad is
secondary to
for for this series it's all fun and i
can't wait to see how it all comes
together but you know like that that's
the thing for jimmy so and
i feel like whatever he whatever his
central conflict at the end it has to
involve her in order for it to be you
know satisfying
uh our
ra9
yeah that uh thank you for the 4.99 i
can't pronounce your name sorry hey do
you think the golden toilet in wine and
roses is kim's golden throne uh no i
don't um my thought on that was that
that was the one sign
initially that made me feel pretty
positive that kim never lived in that
house what do you guys think about the
the kim's golden throne theory
no i i think that no no woman would want
any part of that um you know you know
how women are you know like everything
is nice and neat and and no it's just no
no no no no
yeah i know it's that's a bit too much i
i don't know what the fixation on
toilets has been for this show not just
the season but the whole show in general
but that i i don't know i don't really
got much to say about that
yeah uh
youtube user 10 thank you courtney's
reviews has an interview with a lawyer
that explains jimmy would be entitled to
the bail
she be a great addition to your chat the
number from the ballet key scam is the
day howard dies
i actually i i
looked up her channel in a different tab
and it looks like she's doing some
pretty good stuff uh you know obviously
haven't clicked on any of her videos yet
in the middle of a stream but it looks
like she just started a few months ago
so seems like she's relatively new but
she's garnered a decent audience so yeah
be always open to uh talking to
different like-minded better call cell
creators in the future for sure i think
should bring good discussion to your
channel for sure yeah
that's cool um i yeah i don't know about
this i didn't see it so i i'll take your
word for it that he would be entitled to
the bail
it seems like you know that seems
surprising to me but there's a lot of
things that seem dumb and surprising
about the the criminal justice system in
the united states so i guess it's
consistent with my experience with it so
far um
you know like i don't know what what you
know i don't know what the the
nuts and bolts are but i'll take your
word for it thank you for that um
daniel cortez two dollars thank you for
that um
i think we'll see jesse with emilio
i think there is a good chance that we
could see emilio um i don't
and that could be like what you were
talking about earlier chase about how
they might have separate
um
they weren't they wouldn't show up
together they would be separate um
like maybe maybe walt is a breaking bad
flash forward but it is possible that we
could see jesse in the better call cell
timeline it just all depends on how much
they can de-age aaron paul at this point
um because yeah i think it would be cool
to see jesse and emilio working together
before that big bust in the very first
episode of breaking bad
yeah i don't think jesse needs to be
there for emilio to show up though
i mean
and i think you lose a lot of potential
when you don't have aaron paul and
brian cranston on screen together i mean
that's what we signed up for
i just never thought of them having
separate cameos before so i'm just yeah
because i mean those those two sharing a
frame is is why we're all here you know
what i mean yeah yeah it would it would
feel kind of like uh it would feel kind
of unsatisfying if we saw them both but
not together
but yeah we'll see
agreed
maximum rock and roll thank you for the
five dollars no comment just keep up the
good work pete big fan well thank you
for that and i will be i have been
working on a uh howard video that'll be
out within the next 24 hours i suppose
uh i i was trying to get it out before
this but
i had some other stuff come up yesterday
so that's definitely coming
thank you again
radio chaos
five dollars canadian maybe we'll see
jesse when his friend combo hire saul
like was referenced in breaking bad uh
i think this is a misconception
um
pretty sure it was emilio it was emilio
and
uh
theory we were talking about about
seeing emilio uh it is true that we
could see emilia without uh jesse it
could be related to crazy eight as well
uh since crazy already knows jimmy
yeah combo is a tragic character that i
would love to see again he was he was
kind of a scene stealer in his own way
um
but i can't really think of a way that
he would fit in that wasn't kind of
contrived at this point like it would
feel pretty disconnected
unless it's just like a very very small
easter egg where he's someone in the
waiting room that we only see talk to
francesca for like half a second or
something like that
yeah
i mean like i said i i like i really
like the character i think the the guy
who played him did a really good job of
making him
kind of infectious like he's kind of
annoying but infectious at the same time
and yeah it would be
it would be fun to see him eric
you need to get going yeah i'm going to
jump but i think what um
i think if we do well if we do we're
going to see walter white and jesse
pinkman i think we're going to get some
dialogue i don't think it's going to be
a long scene but i think it may be more
than just
um
like a in a restaurant or something of
that nature i think we're going to see
something whether they have to do the
de-aging or whatever i don't know and i
don't even really care at this point um
you know okay mike i mean nobody i know
right right yeah i mean you could even
make age mike if you want to make him
even older and i still wouldn't care
everyone loves mike but i i think we're
going to see some dialogue and i think
it will be more than just fan service
it'll it'll cater to the story
but you know six episodes are going to
be flying by like we're all saying we
have to wait we have to wait these until
july whatever it's going to be here
before we know it and then we're gonna
be crying because it's over you know and
then we're gonna be here but we're gonna
be having therapy on this show in our
shows trying to deal with the post post
better call us all world but yeah and i
wish i could stay all night i do have to
jump because they have some functions
tomorrow um
but i want to thank you this has been an
absolute pleasure i just see you're
doing a fantastic job here on the
channel i watch i've been watching your
live chat tonight too i see a lot of
really cool faces in there some that i
know and chase i'm a big fan of your
your work as well as you know we talk on
twitter a lot and stuff like that so an
absolute pleasure and um and again i
learned so much from from both you guys
tonight all the people in the chat i
never ever profess to be a know-it-all
when it comes to i just push buttons and
talk about the shows that i love and
it's a lot of fun
yeah thanks for coming on man i i was i
was um i was i really like what you're
doing over there i think people should
check it out um
a lot of i mean
you've got access to a lot of these
people that we're talking about week in
and week out and i think you get some
pretty good insights out of them and um
you know we'll be doing this uh i don't
think we're gonna be doing this
throughout the the break but we will be
doing this for the last six episodes and
there'll be some additional streams in
there mixed in for sure so hopefully we
can have you back in the second half
and uh you know get get a little bit
more of what you're thinking about how
things are playing out do you want to um
just plug plug your stuff a little bit
here sure well as i told you off the air
as well too i'll tell your viewers right
now as well too i'm going to invite you
to come over and be a celebrity guest
host uh for an episode in the end
because we're we're going to be carrying
this show we're going to be finishing
inside the gila versa in season three
we're in our about 11th episode right
now of season three and we've renewed
until january of next year with some of
our sponsors so we're sticking around so
i'm going to invite you over and i don't
know who the guests will be but it'll be
a great guest and you can be a co-host
for the night with me but this coming
friday we have
uh julian emery and jeremy schamos who
play uh obviously the kettleman's and
they're not going to be in character
this time they're just going to be
themselves i'm sure we'll get some
kettleman mannerisms but uh that's this
friday night at nine o'clock eastern and
then we're going to be doing a bit of a
ozark slash i better call saul uh
crossover with uh one of um
uh well i shouldn't say that well yeah
it's it's an actor from from ozark who's
a huge better call saul fan who's also
playing in stranger things as well too
and we're not going down the ozark
rabbit hole i love that show but i one
show is enough so that'll be coming up
and uh gordon smith is coming up again
the first second time on the show
and uh other than that i don't know who
else it's i have to look at the notes
but every friday night 9 o'clock eastern
and um and i think you've got the links
in your description so thank you for
that as well too
yeah definitely and yeah i i would love
to come on there and and talk with you
and uh
i think it's uh it's such a cool uh you
know it's such a cool story how you how
you contacted uh tom and you guys ended
up hitting it off and doing that so uh
it's great work that you're doing
everyone should check it out and
like i said we'll definitely have you
back and i'll see you over there so
thanks for coming out my pleasure and
for the record tom still doesn't like
the name inside the gilliverse he told
me that he doesn't like the name
yeah i heard you saying that but
i i kind of get it i i didn't really get
why he had an aversion to it until i
heard the the first one where you had
vince come on yeah and uh and vince said
that it's really you know it's really a
misnomer because
so many people work on it you know what
i mean but i think it's a i think it's a
good name i think it it
that's the way we all kind of think
about it i know you said you got it from
from something that peop
that pete said yeah
peter gold said so yeah i think i think
it's fitting and uh
you know i i'm fascinated with tom i
think he's really great but maybe he's
wrong here oh yeah that's funny but i
did steal it from peter and i'm waiting
to get a bill in the mail for what i owe
him further for the name but tom i love
tom i love his family he's he's great
he's been really good to me he's become
a very good friend now and he's one of
the kindest people on the planet and he
just happens to write some of the best
episodes in television so there's that
love you tom
all right well all right we'll see you
we'll see you soon have a good one thank
you so much
bye
all right so back to it
how are you doing on time chase
um doing good uh i guess we're getting
close to the two hour mark it all
depends uh guess how many more super
chats come in and uh if you have other
plans afterwards i feel like we could
probably go up to the two hour mark here
yeah definitely um i i
i we should be able to get through a
little bit faster
the the remaining super chats that are
here and then we'll we'll reassess when
we get to the end there
reginald ask thank you for the 9.99
could we see some origins of how jesse
started cooking as chili pee or some
classroom scenes when walt and jesse's
walt was jesse's chemistry teacher i
mean these things are all things that
could
could happen i the the court the
classroom scenes and and
and all of that i mean that's all origin
story stuff for
for breaking bad but i don't really know
how it serves
the jimmy mcgill story i mean there
would have to be some connective tissue
there what do you think
uh well i think that's an interesting
theory i think there are a handful of
theories in regards to seeing uh them in
the prequel timeline in the better call
stall timeline but again it just has to
do with how well they're gonna be able
to de-age the actors if so i guess if
they show walt during the better call
saw timeline one pro is that he won't
you know have to wear a bald cap because
he still has his hair but then a con is
that uh you know walt doesn't get into
the criminal world until uh 2008 when
breaking bad starts so if we're going to
see anything criminal you know whether
it's the chili pea recipe or whatnot
it'll have to be jesse but otherwise i
just don't think there's
that much interesting stuff that they
could do with wall pre-2008 since he's
not necessarily you know a criminal yet
there is a handful of options but i i
think i would prefer to see some sort of
breaking bad flash forward kind of a
missing scene that uh you know type of
thing you saw in el camino
yeah and like i think a lot of those
details like i said they don't really
bother me as much like i know people
want insane about the the bald cap on on
an el camino and that just really wasn't
something that that ever affected the
you know the
the experience for me yeah like i
noticed it but i also noticed that there
it's a it's a movie and that everything
in it is is kind of
made up you know what i mean i don't
know like it seems like weird details
that people obsess on that that that
really don't take away from from my
experience anyways
yeah i agree i didn't really notice
anything with that while watching the
show apparently not only was there a
bald cap but they also kind of cgi'd his
head to look smaller so maybe that's
where the uncanny valley that some
people are talking about maybe that's
where it came from but it definitely
didn't bother me at all honestly i was
just like
go ahead
i was just gonna say and even the other
better call saul characters like yeah if
you look at mike and gus and better call
saul and then you go look at them in
breaking bad just going directly from
one to another could possibly be a
little bit jarring but just watching
better call saul as is like i really
have no complaints at all
yeah like with the with the the el
camino thing i mean i was just like
that's walter white you know i was just
pumped that that he was in the movie you
know what i mean
i
i
i i didn't really feel the need to to
to justify the uh the the details you
know i mean it was just like hell yeah i
wanted to see walt and jesse show up and
they did you know
yeah again i feel like you really have
to scrape the bottom of the barrel to
find any sort of complaints within this
universe for the most part i just really
enjoy it as is
yeah uh paul berry thank you for the
five dollars do you think that kim knew
that being saul had consequences
um i think no i think that was part of
the lesson that they learned was that
they might be really good at what
they're doing and plan things out but
they they didn't have as much control as
they thought they did and uh and it had
terrible consequences i think that was
part of the
the lesson because otherwise i think
they just go and
um
continue to do that you know i mean like
they are really good at scamming people
and
what when do you ever stop you know i
mean it's like one of those things like
if you you know if you if you have if
you had a scam that you could get make
some money and that wouldn't nobody
would find out about it and nobody would
get hurt in the immediate
aftermath
what's going to stop you from doing that
every time that you need money you know
what i mean like it's it's not something
you can just walk away from when it's
working and
i mean i think they vaguely understood
that i just think that they thought that
they could they could handle anything
because they were going to be prepared
and and it didn't work out that way
yeah i mean uh it goes a lot into what
tom said on the
hollywood reporter interview and uh
the insider podcast is that howard's
death is really the major consequence to
get them to realize that you know their
actions do have consequences uh even
ones that they could have never
anticipated so i don't think she knew
about consequences beforehand but this
is definitely an eye-opener for her and
that's exactly what the creators were
going for
yeah and the fact the fact of the matter
is jimmy did know because he already did
that but he never explained that to her
you know what i mean like him doing the
the the insurance thing like that pretty
directly led to to his brother's death
like even more so than what's happening
with with howard in a way you know i
mean like
he did something senseless just to
just because he could
and
that that actually was what
you know before that chuck was actually
doing well he was recovering he was you
know what i mean he was living life
again and that insurance thing is what
sent him
to to to his demise you know
yeah that's the whole thing and just so
sort of the consequences for both of
them is different because for kim it's
you know knocking her down a pig making
her realize that her consequences do
have actions and then for jimmy it's a
consequence for him because he knew
about all this because of chuck but he
he didn't learn his lesson and now it's
happened again
yeah and he wasn't even so much of that
it was that he couldn't say no to her
you know i mean like he he he was he was
hesitant to get into it but not enough
to say no i'm not going to do this
because he he can't really say no to her
so
it's a fascinating situation
matthias munchmeier
thank you for the clp-1000 have you seen
the last of have we seen the last of
kim's
mom
gold thinks no
well uh well i don't know what he's
refer i don't know what he's referring
to when he says gould thinks no like
gold a lot of times will say things like
we may not have seen the last of her
you know
because he doesn't want to be fighting
about it
yeah so i don't know
do you know of any time when he said
that that we have not because if if
peter gould said that we will see kim's
mom again
then um
we will because he's in charge of
the show right
but i think that he's he's trying to be
vague i don't know i mean i i don't know
it's definitely possible i would like to
see more but um just depends how
trying to be with it like i feel like
the context of when he said that really
matters because i def i don't know with
an article interview or an actual
interview i haven't i know they just did
a bonus inside or sorry thinking about
eric i know they did a bonus insider
podcast uh just talking about season six
and yeah they talked about american
greed i think it just went out uh today
or yesterday i haven't checked it out
yet so maybe he said it on there but uh
playing with the idea that maybe we will
see kim's mom again uh maybe that
implies that she did survive maybe she
did go to jail um i don't know if maybe
she'll get released or if kim goes back
to her hometown maybe we'll get a kim
visits her mom in jail scene but again
it all depends you know what they want
to do with the story how kim's fate ends
up and the limited time that they have
left
yeah yeah i listened to the insider this
morning um
it was uh they i don't think he said
anything on there it wasn't peter didn't
do a lot on that one it was a lot of
vince because he's it turns out he's a
big fan of of american greed and they
they talked about the process of that a
lot more than anything and it's good
it's a good episode but
yeah i'll definitely be checking later
tonight i just haven't gotten around to
it yet i was doing other stuff earlier
yeah mo four low thank you for the five
dollars any chance of a post breaking
bad series featuring gene
after bcs is finished i just don't think
that they're i mean i take them at their
word that they're done with this
universe now i mean they've been doing
it for 15 years
and there's a part of me that would like
to see more but there's also a part of
me that would like to see what else they
do outside of that universe
yeah i don't think that we're gonna see
another full series it's possible we
could get a gene netflix movie special
kind of like el camino i mean if they
ever do if vince ever has story that he
wants to tell maybe two three four years
down the line he could
you know eventually return just kind of
like how he brought el camino into
fruition but i feel like maybe they
might leave the gene ending open-ended i
don't know if that'd be disappointing or
if they could do it in a satisfying way
but to be honest i would personally like
to see an entire netflix movie just
about gene but that's about it i don't
think there's going to be a full gene
series so to speak
yeah
no david roberts thank you for the five
dollars has anyone asked if episode 8
could be a gene only episode
uh no
we nobody did ask that today um
i don't think that there's a pos i don't
think that's the way it'll go i think
that
there's an outside possibility that
there could be a gene
like the the traditional uh
flash forward
you know just cold open but i i think
that we're gonna not get to gene until
we get to gene is is kind of how
my my thought thoughts are
i think episode eight will pick up right
where um episode seven left off
like you know like
right where it left off like he'll he'll
lalo will say the next uh thing that he
was gonna say after let's talk
it's it is a vince gilligan episode um
but i don't know anything else that
would that makes me would would make me
think that we would go into gene at this
point
yeah i i don't think we'll see jean in
episode 8 just purely because they wrote
the season not knowing that it would get
split until afterwards maybe if they did
know that their part 1 and part 2 going
into it they could kind of start it off
with the gene scene but i as much as i
want to i i don't really think that's
going to happen even with the kind of
trailer trickery that that uh teaser
gave us in kim's apartment
yeah i think that you know i i did a
video talking about that and i mean i
think the video that that teaser was
just supposed to be you know evocative
it's just supposed to make us think
about
you know where we're headed and um
jean is in that future there's also you
know that empty apartment where they
don't live there anymore and
all that stuff is just more it's just
more uh you know visual
than it is anything that we can expect
to see
whisper gaming thank you for the 999
theories about
kim zafiro anejo stopper peter says we
need to keep an eye on it and it was
described as sharp in 606.
might she use it to self-harm or harm
someone else we already answered this
earlier whisper gaming
um someone asked the exact same question
i don't know that i have any more to add
on this um
how about you chase
uh not really i'll just say i don't
think kim is gonna self-harm herself and
if she does use it to kill someone it
should be someone that jimmy knows about
and so if jimmy still thinks lala's
alive and breaking bad as shocking as it
would be i don't think that kill is
gonna or kim is gonna kill lalo
yeah i i i don't think self-harm would
would would make a lot of sense and and
and how i expect the the last part of
the season to play out but you know i
could be wrong too
um
it would be weird to me if jimmy kept
that if it was involved in any kind of
cell phone self-harm of the woman that
he loves um
you know like if someone
if someone commits suicide you don't you
don't really keep
yeah something like that i mean after
the fact
yeah um and again who knows if it's the
exact same bottle stopper or if you just
got another one from another bottle of
zafira nejo uh it's kind of the same
thing with the uh the painting that i do
i know it's i know it's the exact one
i feel like i do
oh yeah well i was just thinking about
the the painting i'm just i'm just
yeah i'm just teasing a little bit but
i'm just you know i mean like i it would
be it would be pretty surprising if they
put that there and then it was just like
oh yeah this is a different one
yeah yeah i was just thinking in regards
to the the painting that uh saul still
has in breaking bad that's being taken
down from his house it's that same
painting that they have the howard con
board on and and howard has his brains
blown out onto it so just keep the same
painting or does he just get another one
that's the same
that's a great that's a great point
though they do have that painting which
is really macabre when you think about
it huh
yeah
i mean that's all
like his blood is is absolutely on that
if not his brains you know what i mean
so there's definitely
they clean that and then he decides to
keep it around that that's that is
something
that that kind of changed in that in the
opening teaser now that that we saw the
last episode
william thank you for the two dollars
gene actually taking the call instead of
francesca
uh now i'm trying to think about the
time the timing of all this uh by the
time we see gene that should have
already come and gone right
yeah yeah i think so
i i do believe that to be the case we
don't know for sure obviously but
um
it would be kind of hard to to construct
a timeline where he disappeared left uh
everything was you know
wrapped up with g with jeff and then he
goes back and takes this call that was
just a few months out from when when he
was leaving as far as i know about it
but
thank you for that uh sarah lee c thank
you for the five dollars do you think
we'll only have walt and jesse for a
cameo
i feel like they need a three episode
arc
but it seems unlikely now yeah i think
it'll be um
i agree with what eric said earlier i
think it'll be something substantial i
think it'll be something story related
that'll that'll
contribute but i don't think we'll see
an actual arc i think it'll just be um
you know like sort of
a crossover
just because i mean i think that they
have to make bcs to stand on its own so
if they get too crazy with it then they
sort of have to explain a lot of stuff
that you would that most of us already
know from watching
breaking bad but not everyone does you
know and they can't really assume that
everyone would
it just all depends um
how far they take the timeline like my
leading theory is that it's just going
to be some sort of maybe cold open
breaking bad flash forward but it is
entirely possible we could get a two to
three episode arc with them kind of like
how we had a two episode arc with uh
hank in season five but it just depends
uh how much they connect the uh the two
timelines if it's going to be a seamless
connection between better costal and
breaking bad because better call saul's
still in 2004 breaking bads in 08 so i
don't know is it possible they could
have major time skips like the one they
had in better call saul season five or
the few they had in breaking bad season
five we'll just have to wait and see how
they merge the timeline in regards to
that if there's still even a gap of time
in between the two shows or not
yeah i i i wouldn't rule out that they
would have multiple
um
they would show up multiple times but
like i said i i don't think that it's
going to be
so yeah i agree with what you said there
that they you know it depends but um i
just don't think that
that they're going to shift
too far on to their their story it's
more about how
it connects with what's going on with uh
jimmy and then the future of what
happens with gene when we get to that
jeremy thank you for the 4.99 will kim
and jimmy's relationship officially end
at some point in the bcs timeline
if so will they split up on bad terms i
feel like now it's less likely they're
going to split up on bad terms but it's
it's always possible um
they might cross line i mean it's very
possible that one of them or both of
them or cross lines in a way
that they're that they're just not the
same people
anymore
those are all possibilities
i think they're going to split and it's
going to be
i mean it seems kind of straightforward
but i think it's just going to be
kind of tragic that they have to because
of what happened with howard
yeah i mean on one hand this whole
situation with howard could be that
something unforgivable that's been
teased ever since the season five finale
but on the other hand i mean the last
time that jimmy and kim got in a huge
argument and they were about to break up
uh they turned around and decided to get
married uh i know that is more
professional than romantic the reason
why they did that in regards to not
being or not you know testifying against
each other but that's just something you
think of every time you think they're
gonna break up they get closer together
so who knows at this point honestly
and they and you know it's part of how
they are i mean one of the things i love
about kim's character is that she you
know she's not
she's not secondary you know she has
agencies she she could do what she wants
but they they are codependent on each
other like
howard called it out in a way
that they're perfect for each other and
that they both have something missing
and and that's what draws them together
in a way that we don't truly understand
yet but i i think that you know people
are quick to look at it and say well
this isn't uh you know traditional
relationship and and maybe it's not
you know maybe they're not as openly
passionate as as you as
you know some some of the the better
romances on tv or whatever but you know
i think that there is a connection there
and that it is
it's essential and so
whenever
they're forced to be a part then that
they both lose something it's not just
it's not just jimmy losing something but
it's both of them
who
you know
can't have this thing that that that
works for them
[Music]
andrew loden loudon uh thank you for the
ten dollars why are people obsessed with
backstory this is already a backstory
why does jimmy's early life or kim's
matter
pretty sure vince is about darkness in
people
um well if he's about darkness i i don't
know why understanding that better would
be a problem
uh
i i mean they they try not to focus on
backstory in regards to
this one moment made this character this
way and they only really tell us
backstories about these characters when
they really need to or when they think
it's really important uh the two kim
flashbacks are are i guess most
important we have seen jimmy in the mail
room a few times and um we have gotten
hints at kim's backstory through
dialogue so they don't focus it on too
much but when they do focus on it it is
it is fairly important and it does give
us a new outlook on the characters um
it's all to supplement the current story
they wouldn't just give us backstory for
no reason everything has a reason
yeah well i i think this idea about him
being
about darkness um
i think that's part of it but i think
you know when you look at it from when
you look at it when you really zoom out
it's about choices that people make you
know
and
you know like i i think at least you
know if we if we just look at
better call saul it's about the sum of
their choices and the way that they end
up and it need i feel like you know in
breaking bad they were you know walter
was
he was a lot more of of heisenberg than
you realized and that that was slowly
revealed throughout
better call saul i don't think it's
exact one one to one of the same thing i
think that
you know
these these are flawed complicated
characters but
we're not really sure yet if they are
uh you know we're just sure that they
made some decisions that have have
turned their lives into something that
they they didn't expect it to be
yeah well you know to quote jimmy
quoting mike we make choices and it puts
us on a road
yeah
that's very true um thank you for that
though uh stephen brunell thank you for
the five
do you think that kim didn't tell jaime
that lala was alive because she believed
that jimmy wouldn't be able to pull off
the d-day cons had he known i think that
was a part of it
i think
i think she maybe also just sort of
wanted to shield him because
i think part of the the whole motivation
for doing this con
like at least for the idea
was that she was trying to make jimmy
feel better when they were in that hotel
room
you know she thought how can i make how
can i make my husband
you know he's just been through some
[ __ ] and like how can i how can i
help him to get out of it and she thinks
well we've always been you know we've
all when we do a scam together we always
come
come together we're always
livened up or whatever you know i mean
it they're they're kind of at their
their hottest when they're doing that so
i think that has something to do with it
but i don't think it you know when you
say that whether you're saying that they
wouldn't be able to pull it off i don't
think that
she was sacrificing his well-being
because she because of her motivation
you know of her wanting to do that i i
think that it's just
you know
part of what we were talking about
before they didn't really see the the
consequences because they they know that
they
they had it planned out you know
yeah yeah i pre you pretty much hit the
nail on the head there i agree with you
i'll keep it quick in regards to that
but yeah i think half of it is a little
bit of kim being in over her head
thinking she can now control the
situation herself keeping things from
jimmy when jimmy used to keep things
from her and yeah i do completely agree
that uh she didn't want to shatter jimmy
and he was just starting to get his
groove back after kind of the week or
two time skip between 603 and 604 and
she didn't want to shatter that again
because she needed him for what they
were doing
yeah
totally i'm sorry i'm scrolling here a
little bit i think we may have have made
it to the last
uh
the last one that was up on the board
all right
all right so we are at uh
two hours five minutes um
let's see
yeah like i was saying earlier
one of the things that i you know that
i've been thinking about a lot more
you know
is this idea of the fact that howard was
he was sort of the last
he was sort of the last thing you know
besides kim uh that that's left over
from the early part of the story you
know the the the chuck
part of the story the jimmy mcgill part
of the story i guess as it is
and and as i've been putting this video
together about him and looking at the
events that led to
that happening
it really feels like we're ready to
transition into the breaking bad
phase of jimmy saul goodman's life do
you are you feeling that
yeah well uh you know tom schnauz
mentioned on the insider podcast that
having these two separate worlds the
lawyer side and the cartel side smashed
together is what resulted in lalo
killing howard in the in the crossfire
of it all so i do feel like the lawyer
side of the show is over i feel like the
two parts of the show have merged they
have become one and yeah the show in
season six feels just entirely different
from the first three seasons as i was
kind of telling you uh behind the scenes
a few days ago like i was recently
editing my season two tier list kind of
baffled me how different the show feels
now compared to then it's true that not
many people know jimmy you know with
chuck howard and kim being the three
that knew him the most and with both
chuck and howard gone as i was telling
you beforehand i feel like kim's fate is
the final key uh holding us back from
fully entering uh just full breaking bad
vibes and even in season five the show
felt like it was entering breaking bad
territory but still with the hint of
better call vibes lingering so you know
i don't think that this show is entirely
breaking bad now but we are just inching
closer and closer i feel like there's
maybe only one or two key moments that
are you know stopping us from fully
getting into breaking bad which is nice
it feels like even though there's only a
few episodes left there's still a lot
that could be said i feel like there's
only a few key moments in regards to
what happens to kim is there anything
else that evolves or devolves jimmy into
saul and then is there one or two more
moments with mike but i feel like for
the most part we're already there
yeah and and and and i think that you
know the part that's really been hitting
me is like i said with i was talking
earlier about um lalo and his gravity
just like pulling everything in
that's what it feels like it feels like
we're being dragged
along with the characters into
this whole other thing and you know that
that we've sort of been you know we've
sort of been uh you know hanging out in
in bcs and and taking in the scenery and
getting to know these characters on a
really deep level and now like this is a
shift where
everything is being pulled along by
something different at this point and um
it'll be it'll be pretty interesting to
see how they pick up like i'm really
anticipating the the opening of of
of the story again in 608 in a way that
i wasn't necessarily right at the end i
mean i was still kind of processing the
fact that howard died but now with a
little bit of time i'm thinking a lot
more about
you know
there's just there's just not much that
that ties uh this guy you know that bob
odenkirk plays there's just not much
that ties him to jimmy mcgill anymore
like kim is really the only person
that knows him by that name in this
world you know what i mean yeah yeah and
that's the thing one thing about better
call saul is it really knows how to do
cliffhangers right like if they end an
episode off with a cliffhanger or even a
season the next episode or the beginning
of the next season really starts off
right where that was with season three
with chuck's death uh season season five
with uh you know everything involving
the failed lalo assassination attempt
even season two with that one episode
where chuck hits his head on the
photocopy store and we're wondering oh
is jimmy gonna go in and help him in the
beginning of the episode is that um now
i do think that 608 will obviously pick
up right where we left off i think it is
possible that the cold open might be
something different could be a flashback
maybe a howard flashback but definitely
after the intro song happens we will cut
right back to them in that apartment
yeah absolutely and i i think we touched
on it a little bit earlier but just to
just to kind of
circle back a little bit i mean i think
that
lalo
he doesn't have a plan as far as as as
as much of anything of just to find out
what jimmy knows like what his
connection is he he didn't he knows that
he left before because kim you know got
him to
talk them down from from killing jimmy
on the spot you know what i mean
but i don't think he was satisfied with
the idea of the the bullet holes i think
he knows that someone helped him out in
the desert he doesn't know exactly what
happened out there but
he figures he can get some information
off off of jimmy by going back and that
you know that's basically his plan for
returning
and then you know he he would like to
find out it's connected to mike because
he has a fascination with mike but he
doesn't really know that for sure you
know he he needs jimmy to to actually
confirm that and then
like you mentioned earlier you know
there could be a scenario where he tries
to get he tries to employ uh or he tries
to get him to you know to bring mike to
take care of this situation with howard
or something
but they're like in they're like in the
chess
part of it at this point like he knows
he knows that that gus knows that he's
there and so there's a lot of that you
know there's a lot of like
gamemanship that they have to do just to
sort of make any moves because it you
know it's all it's all rushing to an
actual
death you know what i mean like
they want to kill they want to kill lalo
because if they can kill lalo before
he talks to el adio then
it doesn't change anything
you know what i mean yeah i just i don't
know we we definitely already touched a
bunch about uh everything in regards to
mike in season five with how he put lalo
into jail and took him out of jail and i
do think that jimmy will tell everything
about the shootout but another thing i
just thought of is that jimmy does just
seem so shocked to see lalo and lalo
could kind of play on that and be like
oh why are you so shocked to see me did
you think i was dead why would you think
i i was dead and that would kind of
infer that jimmy knew about the
assassination attempt and well who told
jimmy and then who told kim that you
know he was still alive so i think that
they could also get information out of
them that way too
yeah and i mean they have to they have
to give them something and then they
have to make themselves
indispensable because if not he just
kills them after he gets that
information and walks away and leaves
three dead bodies in that apartment
yeah well that's the whole thing with uh
with walt and jesse still having gus
keep him alive because he needs gus
needs them alive because they're his
cooks like once once gayle was going to
take over then they would have been
disposable and that's why they went and
did that so i definitely agree with you
that jimmy and kim need to not only give
them enough information to get off of
their backs but they need to
prove that they're still going to be
valuable to him in the future to keep
them alive
yeah
and big mac
076 thank you for the 499 and they asked
do we really think that jimmy will
actually be mad at kim for not telling
him that lalo was still alive and i and
this is sort of what i was talking about
i don't really see
i really don't see how that that plays
into what's happening because they're
like in survival mode you know what i
mean they're uh
they're they're they're gonna keep going
and uh they're gonna have to
fight for their lives so i just don't
see how
he could really develop that in anything
that would be important you know he
might be hurt by it but
i don't think they're going to be
dealing with that you know
and again well it depends if all cards
go out on the table in regards to kim
admitting that mike went and talked to
her about it um i do maybe think that
afterwards they might have a small
discrepancy about it but i don't think i
think they're gonna have more serious
things on their mind where they're gonna
say okay let's let's deal with this
whole lala situation and us surviving
and then you know maybe if we have time
to talk about that later then we can do
so but you know there's a time and a
place
yeah and north
north northern tau thank you for the
tent uh there was a fake ethics video
from 2020 that showed an animated kim
doing lol lawyer stuff for vomitos pests
with walter as mr mayhew just a bit of
fun do you know what this is
uh yeah that's in regards to the ethics
training like video series that uh racy
horn actually got nominated for or even
won an award for back uh during season
five how they did uh i know they did uh
gus a los poyos videos and then they did
security training with mike i believe so
yeah those series are
yeah yeah so it's just the season five
one of that and yeah those series just
try to shove as many easter eggs in
breaking bad better call saul easter
eggs into those videos as possible
whether it's the actual actors talking
about stuff or if it's the little fun
animations that they do so yeah i just
think it's it's a bit of fun honestly
it's it's really fun to watch for people
that know the breaking bad universe like
so well but that's about it honestly
yeah and i've heard that they're going
to be doing them uh with some of the
side characters this season
i don't know if that's common knowledge
or whatever but i read that somewhere
yeah well i know they're doing that
animated slip in jimmy spin-off which
i'm not too into to be honest i'll give
it a chance but you know uh and then
they're doing uh another series of ray
seahorn playing a different character
i'm not sure where it's either like new
york or la or something like that but
she oh i think it's la because i think
she's like uh kind of like a hollywood
director or something i don't know if
that's gonna be canon or what the heck
the deal is with that honestly
um it's not
she's not kim and i i watched the first
episode of that whenever the screeners
came out i watched uh i haven't got
got around to it but she's a totally
different character
okay yeah but ray ray does uh she she
writes and directs some of that and it
looked it looked interesting the first
the first uh
thing it's sort of like a small cast and
you know three people in the in a room
kind of thing where they're just uh
doing different things so i mean it
might be cool the i haven't seen i saw
the trailer for the slip and jimmy
cartoon and it looked like it wasn't
really
it looked more i don't know it looked
more like it was maybe for
a different
i didn't think i felt like i was in the
target demographic for that yeah me too
i don't really know who i don't really
know who that's for to be honest i mean
i i feel like
yeah
they could have done a lot with that but
i don't know
it's out now right i mean i don't know i
think the first two episodes or
something like that i don't know i
haven't i haven't seen it to be honest
i've just seen the trailer
yeah i haven't had time for it i saw the
trailer and it didn't it didn't suck me
in but we'll see
i'll reserve judgment to see what the
rest of it looks like strange waffle
thank you for the dollar
matt sandlin thank you for the 9.99
there's still four years until breaking
bad
still need to see qb saul defend emilio
saul money laundering plus we still need
to see gene's ending what is your
prediction for the timeline i don't
think we need to see any of those things
i mean i i think
uh
it would be okay if we saw all of them
but i don't think that we need to see
any of those i think we've seen enough
to understand how
the guy who was in better call saul
and
you know the guy who's in breaking bad
would do all of those things like how
they would make sense for him to do
those
i think the timeline that's something i
wanted to talk about today i'm not 100
certain um
i do feel pretty strongly that there
will be at least
the last episode will be gene i i feel
pretty
confident that the last two will be gene
almost entirely but there could be some
some crossover but what i'm wondering
about is like
how much more
how much how many how many episodes
could this current situation with lalo
actually take up
what are your thoughts on that chase
i mean i guess lala was kind of one of
the only things that are standing left
in the better call cell timeline i i do
think that we'll get at least three more
episodes in the better castle timeline
with 610 possibly being the better call
saul timeline finale episodes 611-613
are up in the air whether we'll get a
cross over into the breaking bad
timeline as i said before depending on
how many time skips they do if it's just
a breaking bad flash forward or if we
actually get a full breaking bad episode
or two uh into that timeline um i i do
think that we'll get one full gene
episode to conclude the series but i'd
be open to get to
uh so yeah who knows with i guess
episodes 11 and 12 are what i'm most
curious about is it just going to be
extended better call stall timeline is
it going to be a mix between that and
breaking bad of just a flash forward
scene are we going to get full on
breaking bad and just get a bunch of
missing scenes to stuff that happens uh
from saul's perspective i'm not too sure
but i do i mean it would be nice to see
qb that all depends if you know bill
burr has time for it i know he was
supposed to be in season five but
couldn't so who knows about that uh we
do know how you know saul gets it we
know eventually saul gets that uh
caldera's contact book so he could just
hire qb through there uh we discussed
about emilio uh already i think it would
be cool to get a cameo from him but
again we don't need it and also it would
be kind of cool to see saul set up some
sort of money laundering because we we
know a bunch of places in breaking bad
that he does launder money through and i
think maybe eventually he even buys the
nail salon and launders money through
that as well because i think the nail
salon is referenced in breaking bad uh
are we gonna see price return and it'd
be the owner of the laser tag store that
they launder money through i mean
there's a lot of options there but yeah
it just depends how much time they're
gonna give us uh in this current
timeline really
yeah i can't really see
when i think about it i i really can't
see how the whole lalo situation takes
more than two episodes
i mean i'm not saying that they couldn't
um but it's just where we're at like
where things are left like
there's going to be direct action and
and like i said i don't think he could i
don't think he could let
either i don't think he could let them
both go somewhere like i think he would
have to hold one of them
hostage while the other one
did his bidding i feel like we're in
that kind of
in that kind of situation right now
so i don't know how they could keep that
up for more than like two episodes and
then like you said one maybe for the for
the aftermath
and then i think from there the rest of
it is is could very potentially be
just gene and
and breaking bad time stuff because
if we think kim's gonna leave
we could see you know that happen
uh in the aftermath we could see
where she's at sort of like her version
of a gene scene at some point you know
but yeah like if you if you think about
like you know the fact that they're
there and and
he's
he's there for a reason lola you know
like that can't they can't really
stretch that out that long uh gus and
his men are on high alert they know he's
there
so you know unless it's like a
a minute by minute situation where
they're showing both sides
reacting or something i i don't i i feel
like
that's going to get tied up pretty
quickly
yeah yeah i could agree complete with
that 608 609 could be the finale of lalo
610 can be an aftermath and then
11 and 12 i'm not sure how much breaking
bad we're gonna get but maybe maybe even
get two gene episodes with 12 and 13.
yeah and uh jonathan mara fuentes
thank you for the five dollars he says
are you worried that amc will milk this
franchise to the floor like they did
walking dead
i i don't think so um
i'm not sure what the deals are i know
sony actually produces the series they
they have the the the rights and i don't
know if that's a difference between how
walking dead is
is uh put together but i i don't i i
feel like i said earlier and i've said
many times i take vince and peter at
their word that they're ready to move on
and i know i don't think that we're
gonna see amc step in to
just make different work you know
different shows inside this universe
yeah i'm trying really really hard to
not talk any ill will on walking dead
here because they used to be like my
favorite show but after after season 8
it just kind of lost me so i see i see
where you're getting that with that but
no i really trust the better call saul
creators i know they'll only do another
story if they really feel like they have
something they're not going to force
themselves to do another prequel or
another sequel or do four spin-off shows
at the same time as soon as the show
ends like i really feel this is it you
know this is it this is the story they
want to tell maybe a few years down the
road if if you know vince gilligan has
an epiphany and has another good idea
the actors love him so much and and
they're always down to come back and do
more but that's only he only does what
he feels is necessary you know they
ended breaking bad with five seasons i i
don't know if it was amc or what they
kind of begged them to do more than five
seasons they said no we're gonna end
with five seasons we're telling the
story we want to tell and uh yeah i
really respect these creators and what
they plan on doing so no i don't i don't
think that they're gonna milk it and to
be honest they already i they already
kind of imply that they're a bit worried
that they're milking it too much with
better call saul which i don't agree at
all i i think better call saul is
amazing but they always have that you
know sort of running the well dry in the
back of their heads so they they're very
conscious of that themselves and they
definitely don't want to overdo it
yeah
and i think uh we can uh start to to
wind things up here wrap them up for
the uh for the this uh episode here
yeah
i'm just i'm trying to read some of the
regular chat it
it's really hard to keep up with um
but yeah i think we could probably um
wrap it up did you have anything else
you wanted to
to talk about before we go anything
related to
the conversation or
you know stuff that you've been thinking
about this week since
there's no new episode
uh yeah i just uh just i i really would
like to see kim return in the gene
timeline
it also explained why we haven't seen
gene all all season long we don't want
to give kim plot armor because we
already know that jimmy has plot armor
i'm really anxious for kim's fate even
if i'm not a fan of her character
anymore i mean i absolutely love ray c
horn i love bob odenkirk and i do love
jimmy and kim but after after this most
recent episode like i would not blame
you or not just you but anyone watching
if you didn't like these characters
anymore it kind of reminds me of uh
of walton breaking bad how he ends up
doing so many horrific things that by
the end of the show viewers don't even
like him by the end of it due to his
quote-unquote evil actions um it really
i think they're really doing a good job
sort of devolving jimmy into saul i
think this howard moment is a big moment
uh
but again they've kind of been doing
going towards this the whole show i just
think that the creators have purposely
sort of steered their characters in a
direction where they want us to not like
them anymore they want us to not have as
much sympathy or empathy for them
just because of the things that they've
done in season six and to that i say
they're doing a really good job i
appreciate you know the story for what
it is but
i mean i i do kind of want i'm not
really rooting for kim anymore i gotta
say i do kind of want her to get her
comeuppance i'm not sure what that'll be
i don't want her to die
but uh you know if something bad happens
to kim i'm not gonna feel all that bad
towards it as you know i would have back
in let's say season four or something
yeah i don't know i mean her dying would
feel as uh you know it'd feel almost as
as undeserving as as
as howards did you know what i mean like
obviously
she didn't know what was going to happen
to make
make that you know like the unintended
consequences of that she made a bad she
made bad choices but you know everybody
does like regular human beings do that
as well
and uh you know i i
i kind of unders like i
i kind of understand some of the
sentiments behind that but i don't i
don't really look at her and and uh
walter white in the same same way at all
um not yet that's not to say that they
won't go there you know i mean that they
they won't make
they won't have her do something that
would feel that way but
um you know yeah i don't know i don't
necessarily want kim to die i don't
think she should die i think there's a
lot better storytelling that could be
done in regards to her fate than her
just biting the bullet um you know
whether she goes to jail gets disbarred
runs away whatever but i do feel like
something uh tragic uh will or even
should happen to her uh more than just
watching howard die in front of her
because that made her realize you know
the consequences of her actions but i i
don't know i still feel like something
has to get something has to happen to
her i like the idea of her going to jail
and not being able to spend the
sandpiper money that she works so hard
to get i think it would be truly tragic
if she got disbarred so she can't do the
pro bono
office that she's always dreamed of um
just something like that you know i
don't want her character to die i think
there's a lot better things they could
do with kim than just killing her off
yeah because i mean if you think about
walter i mean he watched he watched jane
die you know like he made that's the
kind of choices he made regularly
throughout the series and people still
loved him like way beyond that you know
i mean we're rooting for him 100 way
beyond that so
i don't know like i i just don't feel
like i haven't felt a turn
for kim like even the least like i feel
bad that howard died but you know it's
not
they're they're complicated characters
so there there's there's more than
you know oh well she deserves something
because of the fact that they they did
this scam you know i mean like it was
definitely ill-advised but it's it's not
up there on like letting
someone die because
you know the relationship might be
getting in the way of like you're trying
to sell drugs you know what i mean
yeah walt walls has definitely done many
many worse things than kim could ever
imagine but
definitely definitely was a bit of a kim
fanboy going into season six and i i
definitely feel like season six has
crushed that for me i don't i don't
really know what else to say i don't
hate her but i don't really like her
anymore at the same time
yeah i mean
the choices that she's made are hard to
deal with and and that you know that
that was the thing and
you know a good character like i don't
like howard like you know people really
like howard like i don't like
you know i i feel like he what he got
was was undeserved and it shouldn't have
happened but i don't i don't feel bad
for for a lot of the stuff that happened
to him either you know like i don't feel
you know like i feel like he was
all of that is just to say that i feel
like he was a great character regardless
you know what i mean
i liked watching him i liked the
performance
uh you know i i you know in my life i've
known people like him that that
you know
i
i didn't relate to that that bothered me
you know whatever however that plays out
you know so that's just sort of where it
comes down is like you know he's flawed
and and
we can all agree on that
and then you have to be like well his
flaws the kind of flaws that i can i can
deal with you know what i mean and
that's the same thing it comes down to
with with kim as well you know what i
mean
yeah yeah maybe maybe if you can't
understand at all how she might find
herself in that situation then you can
you can quickly say okay well
i'm done with her like i don't i don't
what the things i liked about the
character are not the thing that i like
anymore you know what i mean so i get it
i i just feel like ever since season
four i've definitely drank in the howard
kool-aid maybe a bit more than you have
in regards to maybe even having a little
bit too much sympathy for the character
and just thinking you know oh howard
howard can do no wrong because that
isn't true he is a very multi-level
character which is again you know why
you're saying that he was a very you
know
well-built character even even though he
wasn't perfect by any means and i think
some some people forget that howard
wasn't perfect uh and ever since season
four which is like how many years ago
now um we've just kind of been on the
howard sympathy train uh this whole time
they did do a really good job making us
care for howard before he bit the bullet
though i will say i will say that
yeah that's the choice that they made
you know i mean like he was definitely
an obstacle to jimmy and kim in the
beginning you weren't supposed to like
him you know what i mean
you you the door opens whenever you find
out it's chuck but even then he still
wasn't that likable you know i mean he
still was was kind of you know
adversarial towards the people that were
supposed to be following so yeah then
they made the decision to make him
likeable you know i mean but it you know
it's just sort of like i said you you
there's certain things that you're gonna
forgive about the way a character is
based on your own you know your own life
experiences and things like that
rod kiefer thank you for the 4.99
breaking bad 508 shows that saul has a
gun in his office drawer we never saw
him use it or how he got it any chance
he or kim
has it in the apartment with lalo
i would say just off the top of my head
zero chance
that he has that in the apartment
what about um
well isn't that the same gun that he
tried pulling out to defend himself
against jesse and then jesse gets the
gun from him and points it at him when
uh jesse was going to use that to
disappear but then he realized that huel
lifted the the cigarette off of him
because he'll just lifted the weed off
of him so
uh i guess we we never see saul use it
but we we did see it come to fruition
with uh jesse grabbing it and pointing
it back at him
um
i'm not sure how he gets a gun i mean
i mean he gets the contact book right so
i assume he he knows how to get into
contact with ira if he ever needs a gun
so i feel like he just has that as sort
of a defense mechanism after everything
that's happened with wallow
yeah
um yeah like i guess what this is saying
is that could he already have it i i
don't know i i don't see the the connect
you know the connection
um
and if he did i mean i i i kind of feel
like
they're not the kind of people that just
pull out the gun and shoot lalo in the
face here and that's the end of the
situation i i don't think that's what
they're going for anyways
yeah yeah i don't know i don't know if
we'll ever see jimmy use a gun or if
we'll ever see gene use a gun honestly i
feel like he just has it just sort of
for peace of mind you know yeah yeah the
way he reacted in the desert whenever
all that shooting was going on is our is
our frame of reference about how he
responds to violence you know i mean
yeah
he's not a uh
he's not a natural in that world like
say someone like mike is you know yeah
lapse of apathy thank you for the five
dollars do you think jimmy has some good
in him do you think he's any bit of a
well-meaning guy yeah i think that they
showed us that pretty clearly in the in
the first few seasons i mean he he took
the he took the money
from the kettleman's he
he gave it back because he wanted to
help kim you know i mean like there's
both kim and jimmy have shown several
times that they can make the right
decision
the problem with jimmy was that he was
doing that for to try to get chuck's
you know to to get approval from chuck
which he couldn't get and i think that
that is
that's more of the question about him is
you know he wants to be loved you know
he wants to be validated by you know
for whatever reason
and um
i think it you know he's a well-meaning
guy at times but i think that that gets
in the way you know like he you see him
sort of bounce back and forth of who
he's trying to be you know getting his
validation from
on honestly i think the whole jimmy
versus chuck aspect of the show i know a
lot of people didn't like how slow the
first few seasons are but i genuinely
just love it so much that whole story i
feel like we could do a whole stream
just talking about the first three
seasons and all these different
instances of jimmy did this to chuck and
chuck did this to jimmy and he won't
admit this and chuck can't admit that
like and i i do think that the final
conversation that they had together in
the season three finale of chuck saying
that you mean well but you ruin the
lives of everyone around you you should
just embrace it that really does does
push them towards saul and then the the
season two conversation when kim and
jimmy went to go get the mesa verde
files from chuck's house um chuck
accuses jimmy of everything and then kim
knows that jimmy's at fault but she
still says to chuck like look you did
this to him you made him this way all he
wanted was your approval all he wanted
to be was accepted and loved and you
couldn't give that to him and and i feel
sorry for him so i think those are two
very powerful conversations in regards
to the whole chuck versus jimmy of it
all but yeah i can just go i can just
spiral down into a rabbit hole talking
about it over and over again because i
really do
i really miss chuck honestly i miss
seeing him on screen i love the
chemistry i get he did have to you know
go it was his time they did about
everything they could with him but i do
think that jimmy you know means well but
he chuck is right he does destroy the
lives of people around him and that
final conversation just has so much
impact on who jimmy is today and not
being able to accept chuck's death and
he compartmentalizes it after especially
after that conversation that they had
and jimmy knows that he's at fault and
he blame lets howard take the blame and
yada yada you know i could just ramble
forever honestly about that
yeah i i i'll stop
i i i there's so much that um i yeah
that's a whole thing that i can't really
get into at this point because
we're uh coming towards the end i agree
with everything you're saying there it
is is a fascinating thing gil and i did
like i don't know six hours of podcasts
about those first three seasons
um talking about that the way that they
developed that and how how fantastic it
was um
you know chuck is he's the
he that you you what he said about
jimmy's right but that that's not the
end of the conversation you know i mean
he chuck it has like he he had a lot to
do with it like he you know what i mean
like he he made a lot of that
you know it's sort of like the
self-fulfilling prophecy kind of thing
you know what i mean
yeah um
yeah there's definitely a lot more to
that conversation and that whole that
whole dynamic in general i was just just
trying to cut off my rambling before i
went too far because you can tell you
can tell i'm passionate towards it but
that is another conversation for another
day sadly because we are kind of running
out of time here
yeah and i i i that's what i was doing i
was just stopping myself from because i
could go on and i really do enjoy
talking about that relationship um i'm
definitely anti-chuck uh he's
also sad what happened to him in the end
but
he you know he was the one that had the
power in the situation and he he behaved
like you know he's we know that he was
brilliant but he he behaved like a
hurt little kid most of the time when
you really think about it which is uh
which is great because that's how that's
how regular people do in the world you
know i'm not i'm not saying that that
you know he had mental illness and he
was definitely affected by
what was going on and and you know it
was complicated but uh
yeah i will i will just conclude you
know that conversation for now at least
by saying yeah my first watch through of
the show i definitely was a part of the
hashtag f chuck meme but every time i
watch through the show i learned more
and more about his character and i gain
more sympathy to all the different
layers of shock and chuck versus jimmy
and i do really think that that was just
a mastercraft of a story
yeah because you know the the this is
the
okay this is really the final word on it
i'm sorry
the the thing about it is you know like
he
it's it's really tragic when you think
about that jimmy cared about him so much
that he enabled him
and you know really his his whole thing
was that jimmy needed to take
responsibility and be whoever he was as
long as it wasn't a lawyer
and chuck the whole time is not taking
responsibility for his own illness you
know what i mean
he has people you know he he
he's
he's he's saying jimmy destroys
everybody's lives you know he's doing
the same thing to everyone you know what
i mean and and it's just it's just so
much fun to just watch it and
and dig into the different things in the
way that it goes back and forth he was
right but still i'm still f chuck you
know i feel sad
but just just the chicanery of it all
right and i'm glad i'm i'm glad we got
to talk about that at least a little bit
because after you saying that you didn't
uh you didn't really feel that bad that
howard died i i i was gonna ask you
about chuck but i guess i got my answer
there right
i mean i feel bad that they both died
you know i mean but it doesn't it
doesn't make me it doesn't turn me
against the other people because of of
the way that it turned out you know what
i'm saying
fair enough that
you know i can understand that
like howard definitely didn't deserve
what happened to him at all nobody did
nobody would you know what i mean yeah
but
but lalo did that
you know what i mean we and we love lalo
but but yeah we're how messed up is that
yeah that's what i'm saying
you know so it's it's just sort of like
the idea that they're playing with is
that we we should
we should feel differently about
jimmy and kim i'm not saying that that's
that we should just stand by them you
know and and whatever but i think i feel
like the way that it looks different to
me is not that like i don't like them
anymore it's more that wow that's way
more complicated than it was last week
you know what i mean yeah
yeah i just love how down to earth this
show is and how relatable it can be at
times and how just even just realistic
and personal it is just
exploring these characters be i guess i
guess we should end it off there before
we go down another
hour long chuck rabbit hole save that
for another time maybe
yeah so go ahead and uh plug your plug
your stuff here before we go
yeah so first off thanks for having me
on the stream it's always very enjoyable
a lot of fun um rece i guess i just want
to plug the video that i just did
earlier today my season 2 tier list a
lot of people have been asking about it
for a while i had to go back and edit
some things due to copyright issues but
i finally got that up so go check out my
season 2 tier list it's literally almost
an hour long i go through the entire
season ranking each episode it's kind of
a recap summary as well to some extent
and uh every week give or take may not
be exactly monday or tuesday but every
week i am planning on doing a tier list
for each season so i've already done one
and two now i'm gonna do three four and
five and then i'm gonna do season six
part one all leading up to uh season six
part two so uh yeah check out the
channel give that some support and uh
yeah pete thanks for having me on i
really appreciate it it's always a good
time
yeah yeah thanks for coming out and um
like i said i don't know what we're
gonna do as far as as
in this break if something comes up we
will i'll definitely be
wanting to stream
um i mean i like doing it either way but
i don't i don't know that
you know we need to come back weekly to
kind of answer the same questions over
and over again for the next six weeks
maybe
maybe not weekly but maybe possibly just
before season six starts we could do
kind of uh you know a preparation stream
especially if they release another yeah
yeah
i'll definitely be doing that so
especially if they release another
trailer but we'll have to see they're
pretty good with not spoiling too much
in trailers so i mean fingers crossed
but at the same time i'd be okay if they
didn't
yeah and um so thanks to everyone who
came out um i was wondering how many we
would get it was it was still pretty
well attended and uh thanks for so many
questions it was a fun time
i'm glad we did it and um i'll let you
guys know i'll be i have a new video
coming out tomorrow and um
next couple of weeks just check out my
twitter or
my channel and you'll know whether we're
going to come back or not so thanks
again we'll talk to you soon